COMMITTEE ON REVENUE TAXATION
DUE TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC WE
ARE CREATING THAT MASK YOU
MORNING PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TESTIFYING. WE HAVE TWO
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TESTIMONY
TODAY IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. HERE IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFYING TO BILL I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCHING THE MICROPHONE.
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO SIX YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER. ON
THE ASSEMBLY REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND SMART
DEVICE TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE OF
PHONE SERVICE. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2098 AND MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU
. I ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WHICH WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMPANY'S WEBSITE
IS ALWAYS. NOW I'D LIKE TO GO
OVER A FEW ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING AND NOW SPENDS. FOR
THE BILLS BEING TAKEN UP TODAY.
WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS.
THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME. THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
FINALLY FIVE BILLS HAVE BEEN
PAROLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA
THESE BILLS ARE FILE ITEM FIVE
AB TWO FORTY EIGHT CHOI FILE
ITEM SEVEN AB TWO FIFTY FILE
ITEM NINE AB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
FILE FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE AND FILE SIXTEEN. BUT ITEM
SIXTEEN AB NINETY ONE I WANT TO
THANK THOSE AUTHORS FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND FOR REMOVING
THEIR BILLS. LET'S SEE. WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET. I
SERVICES SUBCOMMITTEE WHILE WE
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE- A
DOCTOR ARAMBULA FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHT SIX SEVEN I UNDERSTAND
THEIR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES YOU
HAVE THEM HERE WITH YOU ARE THEY
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. EIGHT OH
SEVEN WILL PROVIDE LICENSED NON
HOSPITAL BLOOD BLOOD BANKS THE
SALES AND USE TAX EXEMPTION ON
LABORATORY EQUIPMENT AND
CHEMICAL REAGENTS. USED TO TEST
VOLUNTARILY DONATED HUMAN BLOOD
. CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT IMPOSES SALES TAX ON BLOOD
DONOR TESTING REAGENTS EQUIPMENT
AND SUPPLIES. ONLY TWO DONOR
TESTING LABORATORIES REMAIN
OPERATIONAL IN THE STATE THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER
IN FRESNO AND THE STANFORD BLOOD
CENTER IN PALO ALTO. ALL OTHER
BLOOD BANKS IN CALIFORNIA SEND
THEIR SUPPLIES TO AN OUT OF
STATE LABORATORY FOR TESTING.
CURRENT LAW EXEMPTS SALES TAX
FROM MOST OF THE PRODUCTS AND
EQUIPMENT USED TO COLLECT BLOOD
DONATION. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
FURTHER EXAMS A QUICK MEANT
CHEMICALS AND REAGENTS AND
QUALITY CONTROL MATERIALS THAT
ARE SPECIFICALLY REQUIRED TO
PERFORM BOTH FTA AND CALIFORNIA
MANDATED SCREENING TEST. THIS
BILL ALSO DECLARES THE GOAL OF
INCENTIVIZING OTHER BLOOD
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA TO TEST
THEIR OWN BLOOD DONATIONS ANTS
TO MOTIVATE TESTING FACILITIES
TO LOCATE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
AM JOINED TODAY WITH TWO
WITNESSES WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING
REMOTELY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX OH
SEVEN CHRISTOPHER STOP WITH THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER
AND HARPREET SANDHU WITH THE
STANFORD BLOOD CENTER. BUT
BEFORE WE BEGIN THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY MADAM CHAIR WILL YIELD
THE REST OF THE TIME TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON WHO IS A JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS IMPORTANT MATTER.
MISTER BENSON THANK YOU A MEMBER
RANDY APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ALONG SIDE YOU AT THIS
IS A VERY DEBAYLE. TO ME AT TO
FRESNO AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BLOOD CENTER PARTICULARLY.
SHARON AND I HAVE BEEN BLOOD
DONORS THERE FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME SHARING PARTICULARLY HAD
THE KIND OF BLOOD NECESSARY FOR-
THE ELLER FAMILY WHO DIRECTED
AND REALLY BUILT THE- FRESNO
BLOOD CENTER TO WHERE IT IS
TODAY- AND SHE- EVENTUALLY
PASSED. BUT WE LIVED VERY CLOSE
AND PERSONALLY TO THE
CONSEQUENCES- OF BLOOD DISEASE
HAND THE NECESSITY FOR BLOOD
DONATION AND OBVIOUSLY FOR
TESTING. AND SO THEY PLAY A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND IT'S VITAL FOR BLOOD CENTERS
TO REMAIN VIABLE THIS IS A ONE
WAY. TO HELP DO THAT AS A
SENTIMENT ARAMBULA ALREADY
MENTIONED ONLY TWO NON HOSPITAL
BLOOD BANKS IN THE STATE TEST
THEIR DONATED BLOOD IN HOUSE
PART OF THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE
COST OF DOING SO IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY EXEMPTS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED SALES TAX FOR
MANY OF THE PRODUCTS AND
EQUIPMENT USED TO COLLECT
DONATED BLOOD YET THE EXEMPTION
DOES NOT EXTEND TO LAB EQUIPMENT
MATERIALS NEEDED TO TEST THIS
DONATED BLOOD. SB SIX OH SEVEN
IS A REASONABLE EXTENSION OF
CURRENT LAW WOULD ALLOW CENTRAL
VALLEY BLOOD CENTER AS WELL AS
THE STANFORD BLOOD CENTER TO
CONTINUE DOING THEIR TESTING IN
HOUSE RATHER THAN HAVING TO SEND
THE COLLECTED DONATIONS OUT OF
STATE TO BE TESTED. ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUE- NUMBER RIGHT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ITEMS
SURE. THANK YOU BOTH- WITH THE
MODERATOR. CONNECT US NOW WITH
THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BLOOD
CENTER CHRISTOPHER STOP PLEASE.
YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN. THANK YOU- OF-
CHAIRMAN OUR ARMY BURKE AND ALL
OF YOU I WANT TO THANK THE
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND- MISTER
PATTERSON FOR THEIR- WORK FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BILL- I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER. AND I
AM. VERY HOPEFUL THAT THIS YEAR-
THIS THIS BILL WILL WE'LL GET
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE- BLOOD BANK NOW
PARTICULARLY WITH THE PANDEMIC
ARE ARE FACING EVEN MORE
CHALLENGES HAVING ENOUGH BLOOD
FOR HOSPITALS AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT THAT'S
JUST ONE ONE MORE WAY TO. EASE
THE PRESSURE ON ON ALL FRONTS
CENTERS ARE AND ALSO ON
HEALTHCARE IN GENERAL BECAUSE IF
WE CAN REDUCE OUR COSTS. ARE
AFFECTING THEM WE CAN PASS THOSE
SAVINGS ON TO OUR HOSPITAL TO
PAY FEES. FOR THE PROCESSING OF
THE BLOOD. AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL REALLY
BENEFIT HEALTHCARE AS WELL- NO
ONE NO ONE INDIVIDUAL WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE FACT THAT WE'RE
ALL NON FOR PROFIT AND WEEKLY
SIR BUT THE COMMUNITY. AND THE
PATIENTS WHO NEED BLOOD. SO YOU
ARE. ASK YOUR VOTE OF SUPPORT
FOR- ASSEMBLY BILL BERMAN. THANK
YOU I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
SECOND WITNESS FROM THE STANFORD
BLOOD CENTER WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CONNECT US NOW. YOU ARE
CONNECTED. HI THERE THIS IS HER
PRETENDING I'M JUST CONFIRMING
YOU CAN HEAR ME GOOD AFTERNOON
YES THE FLOOD CLEAR. WONDERFUL
WELL THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I'D LIKE TO ECHO
MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS STOBBS
APPRECIATION FOR THE SUPPORT
THUS FAR FOR EIGHTY SIX ZERO
SEVEN. I'M CORPORATE CENTER ON
THE FIELD STANFORD BLOOD CENTER
AND SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY SIX OF
SEVEN- I THINK IF YOU'RE JUST A
FEW QUICK COMMENT STANFORD BLOOD
CENTER- WE'VE MAINTAINED A
HIGHLY SKILLED DONOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE TESTING LABORATORY SINCE
THE BLOOD CENTERS BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND
THROW ALL THESE YEARS OUR DONOR
TESTING LAB OPERATION HAS
ALLOWED US TO KEEP JOBS IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY FOR BOTH
LICENSED LAB PROFESSIONALS. AS
WELL AS ON THE JOB TRAINING
TRAINED EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING OUR
LABORATORY OPERATION. I DON'T
HAVE THE LAPTOP ON US TO PROVIDE
ALL OF THE FDA MANDATED TESTING
DAY IN AND DAY OUT. TO ENSURE
TIMELY AND ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
LIFESAVING BLOOD PRODUCTS IN OUR
OWN LOCAL COMMUNITY. WITHOUT
HAVING TO FACE THE RISKS THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH OUTSOURCING
THIS CASTING. INCLUDING
INCLEMENT WEATHER LOS AMPLE
AIRLINE DELAYS- ALL OF WHICH
AFFECT THE AVAILABILITY OF THOSE
BLOOD PRODUCTS AS WE CAN'T
RELEASE ANYTHING WITHOUT THIS
MANDATED TESTING. IN ADDITION TO
SUPPORTING THE ROUTINE OPERATION
DURING TIMES OF VERY DIFFICULT
HEALTH CHALLENGES IN OUR
COMMUNITY INCLUDING IN THE PAST
THE AIDS EPIDEMIC IN THE CURRENT
CODE NINETEEN GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT WE ARE. STILL FACING OUR
LAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA ALLOW US
TO RESPOND QUICKLY TO THE NEEDS
OF OUR LOCAL PATIENTS. HERE AND
ADD TO THE SCIENTIFIC DATA AND
LEARNING BY IMPLEMENTING BALLOTS
HAD KNOWLEDGE THAT CASTING.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL TO DO SO. BETWEEN
BOTH CAN'T BLOOD CENTER AND
CALIFORNIA BLOOD CENTER ARE
DOING A TESTING LAB- OUR STATE
IS STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
ABILITY TO TEST AND RELEASE
THESE BLOOD PRODUCTS IN TIMES OF
DISASTER EVENTS. SUCH AS THE
CAMERA BUTTON TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND ONE WHEN GROUND AND AIR
TRAVEL WAS EXTREMELY RESTRICTED
SAMPLE OULD NOT MAKE IT TO THE
DESIGNATED TESTING LAB IN THAT
SCENARIO. WHILE OUR LABS ARE NOT
BUILT FOR LARGE VOLUME WE WOULD
DEFINITELY BE ABLE TO HANDLE
BETWEEN OUR TWO LABORATORIES THE
TESTING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO ALLOW THE MOST
CRITICAL BLOOD PRODUCTS TO BE
TESTED AND RELEASED TO ENSURE
PATIENT SAFETY IS NOT
COMPROMISED. AND WITH THE HELP
OF THE EXEMPTION DESCRIBED AND
BILL- INNISFAIL- WE CAN TEND TO
KEEP OUR DONOR TESTING LAB IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OPERATIONS FOR
THE GOOD OF OUR PATIENTS OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY. AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AT LARGE TO
PROVIDE THIS CRITICAL HEALTHCARE
SERVICE IN THE EVENT OF BATON
PLAN DISASTERS ARE MATH CASUALTY
EVENT. AGAIN I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND- AT IMPORTANT
MEASURE AS DESCRIBED IN EIGHTY
SIX SEVEN AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
WITH THE MODERATOR A ARE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITH THE MODERATOR
NOW PLEASE OPEN THE MAINLINE FOR
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX OF
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OPERATOR
WE'LL OPEN THE LINE NOW FOR ANY
UP OPPOSING TESTIMONY PLEASE.
FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. SIX OF SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE MINUTE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH LINE. LINE
FORTY FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT YOUR
MEMBERS NEGRONI HAPPILY IN
CALIFORNIA CITY I WAS ACTUALLY
CALLING IN. MORE THAN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED FOR DECADES NOW
MADE CALIFORNIA CITY HAS- TIME
OPPOSING SUCH AN EXEMPTION
THEY'RE NOT CONTINUE IN THE
BUDGET AND I DO NOT- EXEMPTS THE
LOCAL ARE TARGETED. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTRACT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. AN A LINE OF THIRTY
FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARLOS MACHADO WITH A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE MUST READ LATER
CODE. HELLO AND ASKS ARE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON IT THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. HI THIS IS BILL CORPORATE
THE CHAIR HAD TO LEAVE FOR A
MOMENT- DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO'S HERE. I'M
I'M VERY OF GIVE MY COMMENT I
VERY SELDOM VOTE FOR TAX BREAKS
GOING TO MAKE AN EXCEPTION AT
LEAST IN COMMITTEE. I HAVE A
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL TRYING TO FIND BETTER.
WHAT GETS A TAX BREAK AND WHAT
DOESN'T- ORDINARILY I THINK THE
FACT THAT. OTHER STATES ARE
TAXING THIS. JUST PUT US ON A
BETTER FOOTING IF EVERYBODY
TAXED AT THE HIGHER TAXES BUT
GIVEN THAT ALMOST NO ONE ELSE
DOES I THINK THIS MAKES SENSE.
SO- WITH THAT SAID DR RAM DEALER
AND MR PATERSON WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I- APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY 2%
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TWENTY TIME IS CORRECT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO GIVING YOU THE
CLARITY THEY WERE CITY. ALL
RIGHT AND WE'RE NOT BEING A
COMMITTEE ANYMORE- DID YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO SAY MISTER FASHION.
YEAH JUST TO SAY- THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION AND
PARTICULARLY- MISTER CREEK FOR-
YOUR YEAH. COMMENTS HERE
KNOWING. THAT YOUR YOUR
POSITIONS- THE OFTENTIMES ARE
VERY WELL TAKEN AND TO SEE THE
DISTINCTION HERE- WE APPRECIATE
VERY VERY MUCH WE THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS WE ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT SINCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM I'M SURE. YOU'LL DO
WELL IN THE VOTE. THANK YOU WE
GIVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT.
AND THEN THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SURVIVED TASTE. SO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS OF.
AB TWELVE OH SIX- PROTECTS
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST AND THE
RESIDENTS FROM LOSING EXISTING
WELFARE EXEMPTIONS AND FACING
SUDDEN AND UNEXPECTED INCREASES
IN THEIR PROPERTY TAXES
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST SURVEY
UNIQUE ROLE IN OUR EFFORTS TO
TRY TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THAT THEY GUARANTEE
THE HOUSING WILL STAY AFFORDABLE
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME WITH
ONE YEAR ONE HUNDRED RENEWABLE
LEASES. THEN THIS IS BOTH TRUE
FOR OWNERSHIP STAKE IN THE
HOUSING AND RENTAL HOUSING
UNLIKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FINANCE FROM THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT HOWEVER. LAND
TRUST CAN LOSE THEIR WELFARE
EXEMPTION IF A SINGLE RESIDENT
MAKES MORE THAN 80% OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME AND WITH INCOMES
CHANGING THE POTENTIAL ANOTHER
PERSON MOVING IN OR- ONE OF THE
RESIDENTS FINALLY IS OLD ENOUGH
TO START TO WORK AND THEN
SUDDENLY THEY MOVE UP. IT WOULD
BE A TRAGEDY TO HAVE IT IS A
TRAGEDY THAT ARE JUST WITH
LOSING THEIR WELL EXEMPTION AND
HAVE SUFFERING FROM SIGNIFICANT
PROPERTY TAX INCREASES- SO
THERE'S NO REASON FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO THIS IS AN AGE. WHEN
FORM OF COMMUNITY LAND TRUST FOR
OTHER OTHER FORMS MANDO ME TODAY
- AS A BEHIND SAKE. ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A CORE. VERY
GOOD SHOW- WE WILL THEN HEAR
FROM US WELL THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH AMY HINES
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST. I'M ON THE LINE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. GO AHEAD HELLO YES
GO AHEAD OF PER YEAR YOU. YOU
ARE HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS AMY HINES STRIKE AND
I'M REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST NETWORK IN
CALIFORNIA CLT ACTION TODAY
THESE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDE OVER TWENTY FIVE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST SOURCE THE
LP'S ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COLLECTIVELY HOLDING
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
COMMUNITY ASSETS FOR PERMANENT.
LEE AFFORDABLE HOMES OF LOW
INCOME OF TWENTY IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS THE LP'S ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY EFFECTIVE EIGHTEEN
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST HAVE ACQUIRED OVER NINE
HUNDRED UNITS OF HOUSING OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS HOLDING THEM
IN PERPETUITY AS PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HOWEVER IN
RELATION TO OTHER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS. ARE GREATLY
DISADVANTAGED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY THREE BY THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TODD GLORIA
ALLOWED LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT FINANCED PROPERTIES TO
KEEP THEIR VERY ADDED PAYMENT.
CODE TO FOR G. IF THERE RESIDENT
INCOME WENT UP TO ONE HUNDRED
AND 40% OF THE AREA IN THE IN
INCOME THE COMMUNITY PLAN
BECAUSE MODEL WAS NOT
CONTEMPLATE IN THE BILL AND
THEREFORE ARE. AM NOT REPRESENTS
REPEAT ADMIN AT. EIGHTY WHAT IT
MEANT IN PRACTICAL. IT'S A THE
L. Q. PROPERTY LOSS THEIR
WELFARE EXEMPTION WHILE OTHER
HAVE BEEN ALLOW TO KEEP THEIR-
MY COMMUNITY LAND TRUST HAD TO
PAY THE HIGHER TAXES ONTO THEIR
READ. YOU WHEN OVER THE- THIS
MEANT THAT IN Y. CASE SOMEONE
WHO WAS A 2% OF AM I JUST 2%
OVER HAD TO PAY HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS MORE IN BRENT. I
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
CONTEMPLATING ACQUIRING A TEN
UNIT BUILDING BE CONSIDERED
SINCE IT WOULD HAVE MEANT NINE
UNITS AT HEARING TO THE AND MY
THRESHOLD AND THE FEAR THAT THE
PROJECT WOULD NOT ULTIMATELY
PENCIL OUT HOLDS BACK. IN
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIANS LOSE
WHEN THAT HAPPENS AB TWELVE
THOSE SIX RECTIFIED THIS UNFAIR
SITUATION WE THINK ARE AMAZING
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB. TWELVE OH SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOB WILL
THE MODERATOR EACH ARGUES ME
ANYWAY. IN THE ROOM WILLING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WITH NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. AND
IT SEEMS NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE
- WHO IS ON THE TELEPHONE LINE-
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AND-
SUPPORT. AND AGAIN JUST NAME-
AND- POSITION AND ORGANIZATION.
OPERANT COMMENTS IN SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE BOTH SEX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THAN ZERO. AN ONLINE FORTY SIX OR MY
COULD OPEN. LINE FORTY SIX YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. WELL I'M FORTY SIX
YES I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
PERFECT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU-
GREAT SO I'M I'M CALLING TO
OPPOSE AB TWELVE ATTACKS MANY
MYSTERY A LOT SOME CALLING FROM
SUTTER COUNTY I'M A HOMEOWNER.
IN A LAND UNDER IN I DO NOT
APPRECIATE ANY HIGHER TAXES.
BASED UPON US SO I'M GOING TO
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU. AND IT WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE LINE.
IN
LINE FORTY EIGHT- MY COULD OPEN
. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TERRA SCRUGGS AND I AND THE
STEWARDSHIP AND EDUCATION
COORDINATOR FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAND TRUST LOCATED IN
SOUTH BERKELEY- WE ARE GROWING
ORGANIZATION WITH ALMOST A
HUNDRED FIFTY HOMES ACROSS THE
BAY IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
COMPLAINING INCUBATION OF NEW
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS WITH OTHER
PARTNERS VALLEJO EAST PALO ALTO
AND ALSO ELSEWHERE- AND THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR US-
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
RENTERS- AND LOOKING AT POSSIBLY
ACQUIRING THEIR BUILDING. AND
KEEPING THEM AS PRIMARILY
AFFORDABLE. JUST AS- AMY. CAN
MENTIONED- EARLIER THERE ARE
SOME PROJECTS THE WEEK PASSED ON
- BECAUSE IT LOOKED LIKE. A
CERTAIN HOUSEHOLD INCOMES YOU
KNOW WE'RE SO CLOSE TO EIGHTY
PERCENT. INCOME THRESHOLD AND WE
WERE WORRIED ABOUT THEM GOING
OVER AND THEN THERE'S- JUST THE
WHOLE FINANCIAL MODEL FOR IT
COMPLETELY FALLING APART AND
THAT'S NOT BEING ABLE TO
MAINTAIN. THAT PEOPLE NEEDED FOR
IT TO BE AFFORDABLE SO THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US FOR US
THEY'D BE ABLE TO CONTINUE AND
MOVE FORWARD PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE. HOMES AND
ACQUISITIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND THEN ALSO JUST
HAVE PARITY BUT OTHERS IN THE
FORM OF A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
EIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL- TESTIMONY ON
MODERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
IN OPPOSITION ON THIS MEASURE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NINE WE DON'T
NEED A MOTION OUR SECOND BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET WE'RE
GETTING SO- WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WELL THAT. WHICH WE CALL THE
ROLL FREE. BUT. BURKE BURKE HERE
WHEN. WHEN HERE GRAY GRAYSON.
LEVINE LEVINE. LEVINE MAYES.
MULLIN. PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOUR QUIRK VERKEHR
RIVAS SARAH HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU MISSILE WE
HAE A QUORUM DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND SO MOVED TO
CORK MOVES ABILITY WE HAVE A
SECOND. PUMAS WITH THIRTY THREE
NORTH. SIDE IT IS BEEN A WHILE-
WITH I WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HOUSING
BURKE HI. WHEN I RATE GRAYSON
LIVING LEVINE IMA'S. ONE THREE
NORTH BETWEEN OUR ARTWORK ART
BURKE I RIVAS PHARAOH HI
EVERYONE. SIX ZERO BUSINESSES
THAT MEASURE IT OUT SIX ZERO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU CAN EVEN. DO YOU WANT.
TO RESPOND TO THE RIVER RATHER.
THAN IMOVIE. ARAMBULA BILL FILE
ITEM ONE B. C. ZERO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM DOCTOR COURT DO WE
HAVE A SECOND. FROM MR LEVINE.
THE TIME IN WHICH CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI IRK
ARTICLE IN. I RATE GRAYSON
LEVINE. I MEAN I MAYES MULLIN
PETER NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK BURKE I RIVAS SERRA
THERE ARE. SIX ZERO MA'AM THAT
MEASURES OUT SIX ZERO MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FOR AB TWO FORTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PREVENT. COMING. I HAVE
THREE PAIRS SO WHICH ONE DO I
MAY BEGIN WITH. AB TWO FORTY
THREE FIRST PLEASE OKAY. TWO
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT THE- AB TWO FORTY
THREE. SB TWO FORTY THREE OUT
WILL INCREASE THE INCOME TAX
DEDUCTION FOR HEALTH CARE
EXPENSES AT THE HELP OF
CALIFORNIANS PAY FOR UP. VARIOUS
APPROVED ON REIMBURSED- MEDICAL
EXPENSES CALIFORNIA ALLOWS A
TAXPAYER SO TO CLAIM A
DEDUCTION- FOUR ZERO. ONE THREE
IN BURSTOW ALLOWABLE MEDICAL AND
DENTAL EXPENSES SO THAT EXCEEDS
THE SEVEN POINT 5% OF THE
FEDERAL ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME A.
B. G. I. IF FOR EXAMPLE YOUR AGI
IS A SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
FIRST THE FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO ALL OF YOUR QUALIFIED
EXPENSES SO DO NOT THE COUNT FOR
DEDUCTION PURPOSES. IN PRACTICAL
TERMS SELF ASSUMING THE STATE
THE MEDIAN INCOME IS A SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND NOT AVERAGE
COVERED WORKER IS UP PAYING
FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS SO
FOR THE- HEALTH CARE. THEY CAN
ONLY DEDUCT THE NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO FOR TAX PURPOSES. AB
TWO THIRTY FOUR SIX TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE THAT THE TAX POLICY
HAS NOT KEPT UP. WITH T. ARIZA
IN COSTS FOR HEALTH EXPENSES. BY
LOWERING THE PERCENTAGE OF
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME THAT THE
TAXPAYERS SO MOST TO X. EXCEEDS.
IN ORDER TO THE DOCTOR THEIR
MEDICAL EXPENSES- FROM SEVEN
FOUR POINT OF 5% 24% THIS IS A
WOULD ALLOW THOSE SO CALIFORNIA
. THANKS PAYER SO WHO ITEMIZE OF
POOL RIGHT OFF I'M MORE OF THE
EXPENSES SO FOR HEALTH CARE AND
UPDATE LAST SAW IN THE STATE
INCOME TAX. I WONDER IF FOR OUR
WAS SUPPORTER OF. THE SUPPORT
THE WITNESS- TO MADDEN SAYS SO
VALUABLE- MOBILE YOU CAN A CHECK
IS AVAILABLE HERE YEAH. I
APPRECIATE FOURTEENTH MATTERS TO
COME TO SUPPORT IN SUPPORT OF
WHAT AB HA. TWO FORTYTHREE.
WELCOME MR MAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
. PRESIDENT BUSH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FORTY THREE. THERE'S
BEEN A GROWING TREND OF
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
PURCHASING HEALTH CARE PRODUCTS
WITH HIGHER DEDUCTIBLES AND COST
SHARING REQUIREMENTS. AS HE'S
HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE TO
GROW INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING TO AFFORD NOT
ONLY THE HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS
BUT ALSO THE CASHIER
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS DEDUCTIBLES
CO PAY. COPAYS AND COINSURANCE.
THIS IS BECOME EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS ARE
NOTICING PATIENTS OFTEN DELAY
CARE DO THESE HIGH COSTS HIGHER
COST SHARE REQUIREMENTS
UNFORTUNATELY THESE DELAYS IN
SEEKING CARE MANY TIMES RESULT
IN PATIENTS MEDICAL CONDITION
WORSENING. LEADING THEM TO HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT TO GO TO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. AB TWO
FORTY THREE CAN PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF TO PATIENTS. I REMEMBER
THE DOCTOR MORE OF THEIR MEDICAL
COST IN PERHAPS PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL MOTIVATION TO TEARS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
. SCENE NINE MODERATOR WE PLEASE
OPEN THE MAINLINE FOR THE
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
A ONE MINUTE THEN. AND WE HAVE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME. ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE MODERATOR WE OPEN LINE FOR
ANY OPERATE OPERATION UP IN
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY PLEASE.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
TWO FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE AT THE END ZERO. IN A
LINE THIRTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS A
- THANK YOU APOLLO'S MACHADO
WITH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION HE APPEARED A MEMBER
OF A EDUCATION TAX COALITION
WHICH IS ASKING STATE UPON THE
CREATION OF ANY ADDITIONAL TAX
CREDITS. UNTIL COMPREHENSIVE
EVALUATION INCLUDING BROADER
TRANSPARENCY IN CALOPHYLLUM THE
CAN BE CREATED FOR ALL EXISTING
TAX CREDITS- BEFORE THIS IS DONE
WE ASK THAT. MEASURES LIKE CHIU
FORTY THREE WHICH IS ADMIRABLE
THOSE WHO HAVE A PURPOSE BUT WE
THINK THE BOTTOM QUALITY IS
IMPORTANT IN THE ACCU. OF THIS
MATTER AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU I ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. START PERK. BOB YES I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS ALSO. IN A
PER WHEN YOU MAKE SOMETHING A
PERSONAL TAX DEDUCTION ALMOST
ALL THE MONEY GOES TO HIGH
INCOME PAYERS THOUGHT MOST
PEOPLE DON'T DO DOCTRINES. THOSE
WHO DO- THE MAJORITY OF THEM
WERE PAYING ONLY A FEW
PERCENTAGE STATE TAX WHERE IS
THE BENEFITS GOING TO GO IN A
MUCH LARGER AMOUNT TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE OF HIGH INCOME EARNER
PAYING TEN TWELVE THIRTEEN
PERCENT. SO FOR THAT REASON I
OPPOSE THIS AS I HAVE ALMOST
EVERY INCREASING DEDUCTIONS THAT
HAVE FOR PERSONAL DEDUCTIONS
THAT HAVE COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE DR FOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON-
DOING SOMETHING- WHAT HAPPENED
HERE- WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS THAT
CORRECT YES I DO I HAVE SET THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE NOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR OTE THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND TODAY MRS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ALSO REMEMBER
NO IN AND THE SECOND COME SEE
OUR TOTAL. WITH HIGH WHICH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EMOTION IS
TO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI IRWIN.
WHEN I RARELY GRAYSON MASON ON A
LEVINE LEVINE I MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK NO BURKE NOVEL RIVAS
SARAH HI THERE ARE NONE. SIX
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO
DOCTOR FOR WHICH HE WAS- SIX ONE
NO FROM SEASONAL SIX ONE DOCTOR
QUIRK YES SIX ONE WHO IS VERY
CONSISTENT ON THAT MATTER-%
MOVING THE FILE ITEM SIX EIGHTY
TWO FORTY NINE DOCTOR CHOI WOULD
YOU LIKE TO IN. I THANK THE
CHAIR AGAIN AND THE MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO A PERCENT ON THAT
SCALE A. B. TWO FORTY NINE. AB
TWO FORTY NINE WITH THE
INCREASED OUR TAX. CREDIT THE
ALLOW FOR RESEARCH ACTIVITIES.
ENCOURAGING COMPANIES SO TO
INCREASE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES FOR
TREATMENTS CARERS AND THE
VACCINES SO TO ADDRESS THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC COST BY OVER THE
NINETEEN. ALSO SUPPORTING JOBS.
THIS RESEARCH AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BENEFITS SOCIETY
AS WELL AS THE A COMPANY THAT
THE- UNDERTAKES- THE RESEARCH TO
ENCOURAGE COMPANIES SO TO EXPAND
THE FUNDS- THAT HAVE- NO
GUARANTEE AWFUL RETURN
CALIFORNIA SHE WITH THE INCREASE
OF THE VALUE OF THE EXISTING
STATE TAX CREDIT FOR RESEARCH
AND THAT THERE WERE DEVELOPMENT.
AS EXPLAINED UP BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ARE FOUNDERS OF
OFFICE. V. EXISTENCE OF-
SPILLOVER BENEFITS- IMPLIES.
THAT THE RETURN OF FROM THE
INVESTMENT IN R. AND D. CAN BE
GREATER FOR SOCIETY OVERALL THAN
THAT OF WHICH APPROVES JUSTO TO
THE INVESTING FIRM ITSELF.
CALIFORNIA IS A HIGH COST TO
STATE OF THAT THE DISCOURAGES
SAY INVESTMENT THAT BECAUSE SO
FAR OPPOSED TO BUILD. THE COST
OF LABOR AND A HIGH TAXES.
CALIFORNIA COME COMPETES WITH
THE ORDER STAYS UP FOR VISA
INVESTMENTS- AND THE NEEDS ARE
MORE INCENTIVES TO DRONE JOBS
AND A NEW OPPORTUNITIES. AB TWO
FORTY NINE WILL INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF- A STATE TAX CREDIT
THE HOPE FOR THESE SO RESEARCH
PAYMENTS PAYMENTS UP FROM 24%
230% AND INCREASES SO THE
CREDIT. FOR QUALIFIED RESEARCH
EXPENSES OF FOR THE- TAXABLE
YEAR OVER THE BASE OF HOME ON
THE FROM 15% 220% I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK FIELDING CREEPS
REPRIEVE A SENIOR DIRECTOR. WITH
THE- BY A COM CALIFORNIA FOR
JOINING ME TODAY TO A SPEAKER IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FORTY NINE
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH FIELDING GRAVES
FROM VIACOM CALIFORNIA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FEEL AGGRIEVED BY A CON
CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
MORE THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED LIFE
SCIENCES COMPANY MEMBERS WHO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
GENERAL SUPPORT FOR INVESTMENTS
TO DRIVE LIFE SCIENCE INNOVATION
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS ALL ASPECTS OF THE
LIFE SCIENCES ECOSYSTEM RESEARCH
ACADEMIA MEDICINE MANUFACTURING
VACCINES MEDICAL DEVICE AND
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING COMPANY
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND OTHERS. HROUGHOUT THE
COURSE THE PANDEMIC AFTER
LEADERSHIP AND BRAVERY TOOK MANY
FORMS THAT WERE PROUD OF THE
CRITICAL WORK OF THE LIFE
SCIENCES THE END OF THIS
PANDEMIC ONCE AND FOR ALL AND
GET US BACK TO THE LIVES WITH
BOTH BEFORE IT. WE APPLAUD THE
AUTHORED THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
PORT DISCUSSION TODAY WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK AND APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR FOR INCLUSION OF
RESTORATION OF THE FORTY PASS.
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT IN THE
BUDGET THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OR DRIVE
OUT TODAY TO CONTINUE SUPPORT
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE MODERATOR
WE PLEASE OPEN THE MAINLINE FOR
SPORT TESTIMONY PLEASE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
FORTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THAT ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
THEN THERE. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU- IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE OPERATOR WE PLEASE
OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR OPPOSING
TESTIMONY. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO FORTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END
ZERO. COMMENT AGAIN ONE ZERO.
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PLEASE WILL
BE RIGHT THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. MADELINE EIGHTEEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. ANY CHILD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO FOUR NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. START BURKE YES- I
AGREE WITH THE TEACHERS THAT
THIS WOULD REDUCE MONEY
GUARANTEED UNDER PROP NINETY
EIGHT TO SCHOOLS IN ADDITION- AS
IT SAYS IN THE ANALYSIS THE RD
TAX CREDIT REALLY ISN'T BEING
USED TO THE EXTENT IT COULD BE
ALREADY- THERE'S ALREADY
NINETEEN BILLION DOLLARS IT'S
NOT BEING USED. AND FOR THE
MORE- I AGREE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE THAT
THE CREDIT SHOULD BE REDUCED OR
PHASED OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEROTONIN. SO
THESE INCREASES I MEAN THE- TAX
CREDIT WAS ACTUALLY THERE PRIOR
TO KOBE. AND THEN I GET CUT.
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE THIS
MASSIVE BUDGET DEFICIT RIGHT.
OKAY SO WHAT HAPPENED THAT
DEFICIT TURNED INTO A MASSIVE.
SURPLUS BUT THEY NEVER
REINSTATED THIS R. D. WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT EXACTLY THE PANDEMIC
THAT WE THOUGHT WAS GOING TO- TO
OCCUR. SO- IT. I AM YOU KNOW
WHILE I AGREE YOU KNOW I
RESPECTFULLY- I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POSITION ON THIS. I FEEL LIKE-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
ENCOURAGE RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
STILWELL'S WHERE- AND THIS IS
JUST REINSTATE BASICALLY PUTTING
BACK IN WHAT WE HAVE TAKEN OUT
BEFORE UNDER FALSE PROMISE. SO I
. YEAH I THINK I'M A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL AND- AND INTEND TO
VOTE YES ON IT THANK YOU. I
WOULD UPSET AS A CO AUTHOR AS
SOON AS YOU IN ALL- ASSEMBLY MEN
I THINK FIRST WE NEED TO
STRAIGHTEN OUT THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COMMENTS ARE COMPLETED
HE'S CONFUSED SOME ISSUES SO I
BELIEVE. KUALA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT YOU SAID
AND WHAT THE BILL DOES. OKAY SO
THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH REINSTATEMENT FIVE
ANALYSTS FOR. OUR ANTI TAX
CREDITS THAT WERE THAT WERE
SUSPENDED AS ONE OF THE
COMMENTERS NOTED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL- THAT HE RELEASED TODAY
DOES INCLUDE THE REINSTATEMENT
OF THAT WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF US HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON ARE EXCITED
ABOUT BUT THAT'S A SEPARATE THIS
INCREASES THIS WOULD GET YOU
SUGGEST INCREASES THAT WHAT I
WAS I WAS REFERRING TO THAT IT
DID GET. TAKEN OUT BEFORE NOW
IT'S REINSTATED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT THIS
INCREASES THAT. SO READ IT IT
MAKES MORE INVESTMENT INTO
SOMETHING THAT EFFORT WE NEED TO
TREAT IT SOUNDED LIKE YOU. WERE
SAYING YEAH I PROBABLY DIDN'T
STATED THAT ALWAYS REINSTATING
THOSE TAX CREDITS WHICH IT'S NOT
RIGHT THE WILL WITH THAT I'LL GO
AND MOVE THE BILL OKAY WAIT
FIRST DR OKAY YOU. CAN GO IN
WITH THE BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SERTOMA TO BUILD A COURT TO WANT
TO MAKE ANY CLEAR. I THINK THAT
THAT CLEAR WE WORLD CAN JUST
THOSE COMMENTS. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
PEOPLE THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NOW
WE HAVE A MOTION DO WE HAVE A
SECOND. WE HAVE A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND WENT AND
TALKED. DR TWENTY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YEAH ASIAN ALL OF THE
DISCIPLINE THAT MAKE
UNFORTUNATELY CONTINUES- AND US
TAYLOR WE NEED TO FIND. A
PEDICURE AND A TREATMENT TO AND
THE PREVENTION AND THE SO MANY
RESEARCH COMPANIES ARE WORKING
ON IT THE HANDOVER WE SHOULD DIE
IN CURRENCY CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
SO- TO DO TO CONTINUE- SUCH AN
R. AND D. ACTIVITIES AND I DID
THIS A SMALLER INCREASE ALL OF
THE A TAX CREDIT THAT WOULDN'T
INCENTIVIZE TO FOR THE- ON
GOING. RESEARCH ACTIVITIES AND
THE STATE IN CALIFORNIA AND TO
CREATE JOBS. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THE MOTION IS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS. MISSILE
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. BURKE
BURKE I. WHEN I GRAYSON GRAYSON
I LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS I
WORK NOW BURKE NOVEL RIVAS SARAH
HI EVERYONE. IT'S SIX TO ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT SIX TO ONE
DOCTOR CHOI AB THREE TWENTY FOUR
THIS COMMITTEE JUST REALLY QUICK
OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS HEARD THIS
BILL BEFORE AND IT SUPPORT
SUPPORT WE COULD CONDENSE BE
EFFICIENT. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WIN AS A SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER C. R. TILL
. I ASK FOR YOU I WILL. THAT'S
WHAT I WON HERE AT ANYONE IN THE
ROOM HERE IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
ONE PRIMARY WITNESS- IF THE
MODERATOR WILL PLEASE A BALLING
FOR THE ORANGE COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU SO MUCH A
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE- MOST OF OUR MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN A
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AN ONLINE
SIXTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN.
ONE SIXTY ONE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME GREAT-
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
. SEEING NONE MODERATOR WE
PLEASE OF THE MAINLINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THAN THE- ONE THIRTY
FIVE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CARLOS MACHADO THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION FOR THE REASONS
STATED EARLIER ON THE EARLIER
BILLS- FIFTY EIGHT IS BECAUSE
THE MEASURE ASKS THAT YOU DON'T
KNOW THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTEEN. ANY TELEPHONIC
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION OF COURSE
BUCKLEY IN OPPOSITION- EIGHTY
THREE TO FOUR. AN OUTLINE SIXTY
ONE. THE TERM MEMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN KAISER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE TO
FOUR THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU AS
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA FACES SAW A
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE DESTRUCTION
SO NOW A WILDFIRE SO. ANALYST
OVER- FIRE APPROACHES HOMES SELL
AT THAT THE VENDORS TO SOURCE
ALL FOR SOMETHING THE FIRE BOARD
INTO THE HOUSE. SO I'M
INSTALLING- PREVENTABLE AND
CLOSABLE- THE HOUSE OF SO WILL
DEFINITELY A PREVENTABLE OR
REDUCE THE RISK OF FIRE MORE
SOMETHING SUCKED IN SO THIS IS A
SMALL. INVESTMENT OF FOR
CALIFORNIANS SO WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE SOUL MANY HOMES ARE
BEING A BURNED. SO THE IS A
SMALL AMOUNT THE THAT WE CAN
GIVE OUR INCENTIVES AWFUL
HOMEOWNERS SO TO IN STORES ARE
SUCH A PREVENTIVA- AND CRUCIBLE.
OF FIREMEN. I ASK. FOR YOUR FIVE
WILL. THANK YOU- MOTION IS TO
PASS TO PROBE THE TIME YOU
PLEASE THE ROLL BURKE HI- I WILL
. BUT WHEN I. GREW GREAT.
GRAYSON I LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES
MULLIN. PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK NO BURKE
NOVEL RIVAS SIERRA. SIXTY ONE
MA'AM DOUBLED THAT FILLS OUT OF
LINE THANK YOU DR CHOI FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WITH ENTERTAINMENT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COME UP AND START
WITH AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX PLEASE. SHEIKH YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX
AUTHORIZES THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIGHT FORGIVENESS
AND TAX RELIEF PROGRAM. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PROVIDING GRANTS TO
QUALIFY COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT
LOCAL RENT FORGIVENESS AND TAX
RELIEF PROGRAMS AS CALIFORNIA
TRANSITIONS OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
IN RETAIL STORES AND RESTAURANTS
REOPEN THESE TEMPORARY
PROTECTIONS HAVE EXPIRED AND
DEFERRED RENTS ARE BECOMING DO.
UNLIKE MANY OTHER BUSINESSES
LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM SEVERAL OF THE FEDERAL
DISASTER PROGRAMS LACKING FULL
RENT PAYMENTS AS INCOME MANY
LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN FACED WITH
THEIR OWN DIFFICULTY IN COVERING
PROPERTY TAXES UTILITIES AND
OTHER MAINTENANCE COST. WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE INTERVENTION
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES WILL
BE EXCLUDED FROM THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS MATTHEW HARGROVE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTY
STATION AND MARKER. THE SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA WITH LITTLE.
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER GRAYSON AND SECOND FROM
IS PETRIE-NORRIS- WITH WATERY-
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. HEY THERE AND
BEYOND THAT ONE CLASS- I'M IN
YOUR POLICY MANAGER FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY AND NOT MARK
SERVER- BUT WE WORK AT THE SAME
ORGANIZATIONS I HOPE IT. OKAY
I'M TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX- GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIRMAN BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE REVENUE IMPACT
MANY- FOR THOSE WHO ARE NOT.
ORGANIZATIONS SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN THE NATIONAL MALL
THERE'S BEEN RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION. WE
REPRESENTED A BURDEN ON YOUR
HEART. BETTER THE TRUE BACKBONE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE ENGAGE IN
NETWORK OF MORE THAN EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND
POLICY. ABOUT KEY ISSUES
IMPACTING CALIFORNIA
ENTREPRENEURS. WITH THE FASHION
FOCUS ON ADVANCING THE VOICES OF
THE SMALL BUSINESSES WHO OFTEN
FACE SYSTEMIC AND STRUCTURAL
INEQUALITIES. OUR RESEARCH
BECAUSE THAT THAT IS NOT BACK
EXAMPLE POTENTIAL WINDFALL OF
HALF IN DENTAL EQUIPMENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. 80% BOB. WHO RUN FOR
A COMMERCIAL SPACE DRUG WITH HE
MAN. FIFTY THREE WHAT PERFECT
I'M MARK SAYING THE MARKET
MONTHS BEHIND ON YOUR RENT OR-
20% OF THE SMALL BUSINESS. BRAND
OR OWN COMMERCIAL. HAVE BEEN
THREATENED WITH EVICTION AND
LASTLY SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
SUPPORT PUBLIC POLICY SOLUTIONS
ALL RIGHT SB ELEVEN FORTY SIX TO
HELP THOSE STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR
COMMERCIAL GRANT IMPACT. OUR
NETWORK SURVEY SHOWS THAT 71%
SUPPORT PUBLIC POLICY SOLUTIONS
LIKE THAT ONE. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE TAX RELIEF PROVIDED BY THE
PROGRAM ELEVEN FORTY SIX ONE
ABLE TO MULTIPLY BONTA TRUCK
COVER EQUITABLY FROM COLD IN
NINETEEN WITHOUT TOUCHING MY
LANDLORD. WE EXTEND OUR THANKS
TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CERVANTES
BETTER STAFF BETTER LEADERSHIP
BIRTH MOTHERS ARE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE. THANK
YOU. I HEARD THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAVE A SET WITNESS SINCE OF BUT
WE ONLY HAVE ONE ON FILE IT
CHANGED. OF LATE WHOEVER THE
SECOND ONE IS. OPERATOR WOULD
YOU LET THEM IN. I'M ALL WITNESS
LINES ARE OPEN THANK YOU. HELLO. MADAM CHAIR I BELIEVE- BONTA
WAS THE ONLY WITNESS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR. OUR. WHICH SHE WAS
THE ONLY ONE I THOUGHT I JUST
HEARD SOMEBODY MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
FOR SUPPORT IN ANY FASHION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS FOR SUPPORT THAT BE
GREAT THANK YOU. FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
NECROMANTIC AND IS A ONE MINUTE
THEN ZERO. M. LINE FIFTY ACRE MY
COULD OPEN. THANK YOU PRESTON
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
SUPPORT. AN OUTLINE TWENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON REX W. HYMAN
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OF THIS WAR THANK YOU
KNOW. AND THE O. LINE SIXTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS KATIE
PICKED GREEN RIVER CALIFORNIA
SAYS HE CAN FOR MICRO ENTERPRISE
OPPORTUNITY EITHER LATE CAMEO
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF- AT
ELEVEN TWENTY SECOND ANYTHING
YET PROBABLY WOMEN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN HELPING SMALL
BUSINESSES AND DIFFICULT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM-
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NINE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WAS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR WE PLEASE
NOW OPEN THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. OUR COMMON
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ELEVEN FORTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND NERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE AND. ZERO
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. READ ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OUR PARK. SO THE IN THE ANALYSIS
IT TALKS ABOUT OPEN QUESTIONS
MOSTLY HAVING TO DO WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM.
HOW DO YOU PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS
IS THE BILL GOES ON. SERVICES
THERE ARE A FEW WAYS WE HAVE.
ONE OF IN DEALING WITH- THE
PROPOSAL STATUTE AUTHORIZING THE
COUNTY TO SET STANDARDS ON HOW
THE CREDIT CAN BE APPLIED- WE
ARE GOING TO BE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
CONTROL WHICH IS SHOPPERS.
ADDITIONAL GUARD WORLDS AS WELL
GUARDING THE COUNTY
REIMBURSEMENT OF APPLIED CLAIMS-
AND I'M ALSO GOING TO BE SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD I AM
COMMITTED TO INCLUDING
AMENDMENTS THAT SPECIFICALLY
ALLOW FOR CARRY FORWARD I THAT
WERE ADDRESSED- IN THE COMMENTS
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS. ALL
RIGHT ARM I WOULD APPRECIATE IF
YOU ALSO MAKE A BUDGET ASK
BECAUSE I THINK HAVING. A BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS- IS A MORE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO DO THIS
RATHER THAN THROUGH THE TAX TAX
LAWS. MEANT SOMEBODY MAY NOT
HAVE A PARTICULARLY LARGE TAX
BILL BUT STILL HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH RAMPED- SO I WOULD PREFER
THAT SOLUTION- ALL SUPPORTED FOR
NOW. BUT I WOULD BE GLAD TO WORK
WITH YOU ON GETTING THE BUDGET
FIX. AS OPPOSED TO A TAX FIX I
THINK IN THE LONG RUN IT COULD
BE. A MORE EFFECTIVE FOR THOSE
WHO NEED IT BUT ALL VOTE NOW TO
GET THE BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HOWEVER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
SILENTLY CALL THE ROLL BURKE HI
BURKE HI LYNN. WHEN I GRADE
GRAYSON RECENT I LEVINE. IN I.
MAYES MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I WORK I BURKE
OKAY WE'VE THIS SCENARIO HI
THERE ARE A LOT. SEVEN SIX THAT
OUT SEVEN ZERO- EVEN FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY TWO
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE PRESENTING
THIS FOR ON BEHALF OF THE JOBS
COMMITTEE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY TWO ESTABLISHES
A TAX CREDIT TO HELP ATTRACT NEW
PRIVATE CAPITAL FOR INVESTMENTS
IN OUR LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
ANNUALLY AFTER ALLOCATED AS A
CALIFORNIA NEW MARKET TAX
CREDITS. IN GENERAL IT DOES
PARALLEL THE FEDERAL NEW MARKETS
TAX CREDIT A KEY FEATURE OF THIS
TAX CREDIT- MODELED IS A CREDITS
ARE AWARDED TO TAXPAYERS YOU'RE
CERTIFIED COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ENTITY CDFI IS ANOTHER. THEIR
MISSION OF COURSE IS TO DEVELOP
IN LOW INCOME AREAS ACROSS OUR
STATE TAXPAYERS ON THE CREDITS
OVER A SEVEN YEAR PERIOD AND ARE
BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF PRIVATE
CAPITAL THEY ARE TO POP THE
DEPOSITED INTO THE CDFI IS ALL
MONIES RAISED THROUGH THE CREDIT
BE DEPLOYED IN OUR COMMUNITY DO.
ENTITIES AND BUSINESSES LOCATED
IN VERY LOW INCOME CENSUS TRACTS
AT THIS TAX CREDIT SUPPORT TO
BUSINESSES BOTH SMALL BUSINESSES
AS WELL AS POVERTY ALLEVIATION
AND ARE CALIFORNIA'S HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES AND AGAIN I DO WANT
TO MENTION THAT ACCOUNTABILITY
IS CRITICAL LET ME FIRST ENJOY
ACCOUNTABILITY IS CRITICAL IN TO
THE IMPACT OF CARPETS ARE. AND.
I DO CREDIT ALLOCATIONS SEASON
FIVE WITH THE- OF THE- CAN BE
ABOUT. WITH MEAT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS MISTER
PHILIP FOR ME WHEN WITH A
COALITION OF SMALL BUSINESS-
JUST. DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES AND THE FLASHER
BARRICADE ASSOCIATION. SECOND WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER
GRAYSON AND ARGUED THAT CAN FROM
DOCTOR QUIRK- WITH THE MODERATOR
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE PRIMARY
WITNESS HAS BEEN CONNECTED THANK
YOU. MADAM SURE. MEMBERS I'D
SPENT. REPRESENTING THE
COALITION A SMALL A DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESSES AND THE
PLASTER BURGER KING ASSOCIATION
. OUR MEMBERS ARE WHAT IS THE
MEASURE- I THINK THE MEMBER.
EXPLAINED INCLUDED- ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF THE BILL BUT I WANT
TO STRESS THAT RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR. THE
BEST EIGHT DOLLARS ARE WE
CHARGING COMMUNITY AND IT MAKES
ALL WATER SINCE WE'RE ACTIVELY
AND SUPPORTED THIS VENTURE AND
URGING RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HISPANIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CONNECT US NOW. A WITNESS LINES ARE CONNECTED
- GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIRED MEMBERS ARE MANY DHEA
THE FORMER THIRTY COUNCILMAN THE
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTED THE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR
COMMERCE- WEBER CAPER HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF OUR LATINO OWNED
SMALL BUSINESSES START- STATE.
OPERA THANK UP. I'VE BEEN WITH
IBM. FEMA CAMP IN PORT MULTIPLE
COMMUNITY FIRST THIRTY ARE
TRYING TIME. I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY BEEN ME TOO THAT
WOULD ESTABLISH THE NEW TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
STIMULATE PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT. IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES. IN MAKE MORE MARK
MARKET MEMBER LOCATED LOWER A
YOU ARE STRUCK. AND MANY HAVE
CLOSED THEIR DOORS FOR BUSINESS
OR LIFE SUPPORT. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED TO CREATE TAX
INTENDED TO SIGNIFICANTLY
ATTRACT PRIVATE INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITY. IN THE LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AT ONE TIME WE HAD
LOCAL REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
THAT FOCUS ON REVITALIZING LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES. THE
FINANCING. OPTION IS NO LONGER
AVAILABLE. THE END OF ONE BILL
DOLLARS CREDIT COULD MEAN UP TO
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD IN THE LOWER INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS. FIFTEEN FUSION OF
NEW PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT
WILL NOT ONLY HELP ARE
STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESSES AND
REVIVE LIGHT WE THINK HOOKED BUT
WE WERE ALL THE GREAT NEW FIFTY
START OF GREAT THOUSANDS OF NEW
JOBS. AND BOOST THE LOCAL
ECONOMY IN THESE NEIGHBORHOODS
THE LOCAL TAX BASE WOULD BE
STRENGTHENED WHICH WILL GENERATE
MORE REVENUE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE MORE THE
THIRD. MEMBER IF THE WIND WENT
WHICH WRONGLY ABSOLUTE JUNK
REPORT. A BABY AB FIFTY SEVEN
TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
MAIN LINE FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. YOU FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN A ONE AT
THE END. ONE FIFTY EIGHT YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU PRESTON
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEEING NINE
ANY- OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE. MODERATOR
KEY OPEN THE LINE FOR OPPOSITION
WITNESSES PLEASE. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
TO CLARIFY IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE ROOM THAT'S IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT WELL YOU CAN'T. SEE YOU
THEN ALL RIGHT COLLINS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NINE RESERVE OTHERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU YES
I THIS TAX CREDIT SPARKS THE
REVITALIZATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN NEED AND IT ALSO
BREAKS THE CYCLE OF
DISINVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- WE'RE GONNA
REVITALIZED AND RE ENTER RE
INVIGORATE OUR LOCAL
NEIGHBORHOODS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE SILENCE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BURKE
BURKE I WHEN. WIN I. GRADE
GRAYSON GRAYSON I. THE MOVIE.
LEVINE EXCUSE ME. LEVINE I
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK HI BURKE I
RIVAS ZERO NUMBER THEY'RE NOT
VOTING. SIX ZERO. THE BILLS OUT
SIX ZERO THANK YOU. MR COOLEY AB
EIGHT TWENTY WHEN YOU ARE READY. GRAYSON BURKE. BURGER OUR
GOVERNMENT UNFAIR MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
TWENTY. WHICH AIMS TO SPUR
LENDING TO SMALL BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY HARD HIT BY THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IT AIMS TO DO
THIS BY ENCOURAGING QUALIFIED
VENDORS TO MAKE THESE SORTS A
LOANS ON A VERY TARGETED BASIS
TO SMALLER FIRMS. ARE ADDED
REFLECTS THE FACT WE DO KNOW
THAT ONE OF THE EARLY RESPONSES
TO THE PANDEMIC WAS THE PPP
LENDING PROGRAM BUT ACTUALLY THE
TAKE UP RATE BY SMALLER FIRMS
WAS LIMITED. AND WE NOW FIND
OURSELVES WITH THIS DOESN'T
CONTINUE AN ONGOING PROBLEM I
DEFINITELY WANT TO THANK MR BULL
BEFORE HIS RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TO EXCLUDE ANY PUBLIC
FUNDS THE SOCIAL PLEASE LET. I
THINK THE I AGREE THOSE SUGGEST
A MEMBERS ON PAGE FOUR- I. I
ALSO THINK THIS IS A- ABOUT. I
THINK THE REPORTS IT WILL ENSUE
FROM THE C. VARIANTS IMPACT-
ALSO ACTUALLY VERY GOOD TO JUST
LEARN HOW THE SORT OF THING
WORKS BUT I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
CLEAN ANDERSON YOU HAVE A PART
TO PRIMARYWITNESSES THE FIRST
FROM THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK- MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH MR BUTLER. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS DAVE BUT LEARNING
CERTAIN ADVOCATE FOR UNITED
CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK. A
COALITION OF SEVEN LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO REGION WHICH
REPRESENT NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND.
MEMBER BUSINESSES 90% OF WHICH
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES EMPLOYING
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE- LAST. WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY- FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
BEHALF OF SMALL BUSINESSES IN
OUR REGION ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
AND ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
EIGHT TWENTY WITH THE SUPPORT OF
A HOST OF BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING. THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTY OWNERS
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND OTHERS. ACCORDING TO THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA 56% SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE EXPERIENCED LARGE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS FROM THE PANDEMIC. 95%
OF THESE BUSINESSES ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH FEWER THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES. IN A RECENT SURVEY OF
OUR OWN I FOUND THAT 72% OF
RESPONDENTS BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
ADVERSELY IMPACTED. THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BEGAN. BUT
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC PUBLIC
INVESTMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY MENTIONED. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
HAS TRIED TO ALLEVIATE OSTS FOR
BUSINESSES BY PROVIDING GRANT
AND LOAN OPPORTUNITIES HOWEVER.
ONLY 46% OF SMALL BUSINESSES
APPLIED. FOR FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
IN CALIFORNIA THROUGH PPP AND
ONLY 17% RECEIVE WHAT THEY
REQUESTED. AND WE KNOW FROM
MULTIPLE SURVEYS THAT ACCESS THE
CAPITAL IS A TOP PRIORITY
CONCERNS SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND OPERATORS. AND IN THE
SPECIALLY IMPORTANT AND SMALL
BUSINESSES SEEK TO BUILD BACK.
AB EIGHT TWENTY PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESSES MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SEEK LENDING CONFIDENTIAL
INSTITUTIONS BY CLAMPING. FROM
TAXATION INTEREST REVENUE. WHEN
IS BANKS FROM ONE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES OF FIFTY OR FEWER
EMPLOYEES AFTER AND- BY THE
COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AB
EIGHT TWENTY IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO LIBERAL LEVERAGE THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. EXPERTISE
AND RELATIONSHIPS OF PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS TO ADDRESS A
CRITICAL PUBLIC POLICY OBJECTIVE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU AIR SERVICE
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS FROM THE
RANCHO CORDOVA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE CONNECT US. AFTERNOON
SURE BURKE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
TWENTY. THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE TAX INCENTIVES TO
CALIFORNIA LENDING INSTITUTIONS
PROVIDE LOANS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. MY NAME IS DIANE
ROGERS MY SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT CEO RANCHO CORDOVA
AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS. I CAN SAY
WITHOUT A DOUBT NOTHING DURING
MY TENURE HAS IMPACTED SMALL
BUSINESS MORE THAN THE LOCKDOWNS
RESTRICTIONS AND ECONOMIC
CONTRACT CONTRACTION ASSOCIATED
WITH CODE NINETEEN. I AM
ABSOLUTELY IN OUR THE
DETERMINATION RESILIENCE AND
DEDICATION OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
DEMONSTRATE TOWARDS THEIR
EMPLOYEES THEIR CUSTOMERS AND
OUR COMMUNITIES. AS OUR
BUSINESSES LOOK TO BUILD BACK
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR HANDOUTS
FROM THE STATE GOVERNMENT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THE HAND OF
A PARTNER. A PARTNER TO SUPPORT
AND SUSTAIN ALL SMALL BUSINESSES
IMPACTED BY BECAUSE OF IT.
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY IS A
COMMONSENSE MEASURES THAT
LEVERAGES THE CAPITAL AND
EXPERTISE A PRIVATE LENDING
INSTITUTIONS. TO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO STAND MUCH NEEDED CAPITAL TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES ADJUSTED
NEW MARKET AND THE NEW NORMAL.
I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND LOCAL BANKS
WHO KNOW OUR COMMUNITIES AND-
THEIR BUSINESS AND THE EFFECT
THAT THEY'VE HAD. THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES COMMUNITY
RELATIONSHIPS PEOPLE AND
EXPERTISE TO DELIVER MUCH NEEDED
CAPITAL WHERE CAN DO THE MOST
GOOD. WE ANTICIPATE THE TAX
INCENTIVES PROVIDED AN EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE COURAGE BANKS
AND LENDING INSTITUTIONS TO
EXTEND NEW LOANS TO BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES LOOKING TO BUILD UP
AND BUILD BACK I THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION AND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WITH THAT- ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
. ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE LINE MODERATOR. IT IS A
REQUEST TO COMMENT SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS RYAN
ELAINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WANTING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
MAIN LINE AND SPEAKING IN A
POSITION TODAY. IF YOU LIKE TO
COME IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE GO
TO LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
. YES YES BY TWENTY FIVE MISTER
HI YEAH I WAS GOING IN FOR
SUPPORT. HI I WAS GOING TO
BRIDGEPORT MY NAME IS REX W. I'M
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION ALSO ON
BEHALF OF I. T. AT G. BOWMAN
CALIFORNIA AND NOW CALIFORNIA
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
AS A IN OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT ON
THE LINE FOR THIS MEASURE.
MEXICO'S LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO PRESTIN YOUNG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT YEAR
TO LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES AS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN CAPITEC
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS WITH ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
I'M CALLING AND CALLING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DID YOU THINK
THIRTY FIVE. YES LINE THIRTY
FIVE GREAT THANK YOU CARLOS
MACHADO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION-
BUYING IN OPPOSITION TO IT A. B.
A. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY BUT THE
CLOSE AT FTA A. B. A. TWENTY M.
SOMEONE MEASURES THAT WOULD
DIVERT FUNDING FROM PUBLIC
EDUCATION PARTICULARLY AT 63% OF
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS
PARTICIPATE IN FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH PROGRAMS IT IS A FAMILY
BACK IN- STATUS. GRANTING A TAX
CREDIT OR DEDUCTION REDUCES
REVENUE TO THE STATE GENERAL
FUND WHICH IN TURN REDUCES PROP
NINETY EIGHT BINDING FOR BUTTONS
FOR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THIS
REASON MUST OPPOSE. EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT
THE TIME THERE'S IN Q. THANK YOU
TO HAVING ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MR COOLEY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES INDEED I
THANK YOU I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL I THINK IT IS
ACTUALLY. TRYING TO ADDRESS
FACTS THAT HAVE EMERGED DURING
COVERT. THERE IS THE ECONOMIC
EFFECT OF COVERT WHICH HAS SHOWN
A VERY TERRIBLE PERSISTENCY AS
AFFECTING SMALL BUSINESS. THERE
WAS AN EFFORT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
TO TRY TO CREATE THE PPP LONG
PROGRAM. THERE IS ISSUES WITH
THAT TAKE UP RATE ACTUALLY
BECAUSE- LOCAL BUSINESSES HAVE
TROUBLE FIGURING OUT WHO LOCAL
IN THEIR MARKET COULD GIVE ALONE
. NERVE THE LONGEST TIGER A LOT
OF DOUBT ABOUT THE- ROLE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO COME IN
AND ACCOUNT THE ACCOUNT FOR
THOSE FUNDS. SO THERE'S
HESITANCY TO TAKE UP THOSE LOANS
THIS BILL BY WORK OF LOCAL
LENDERS GIVE SMALL BUSINESSES A
CHANNEL FOR SMALLER BUSINESSES
TO ACCESS CAPITAL FROM KNOWN
LENDERS. AND IT IS VERY NARROW
IN ITS IMPACT IN TERMS OF TYPES
OF LOANS AND CUTS WITH THE TAX
LOSS. I THINK IT IS. RESPONSIVE
TO THE CURRENT CRISIS BUT ALSO
RESPONSIVE TO THE DEFECTS IN
HOUSE ON THE FEDERAL FUNDS.
OPERATED THE FACT IS OF LIMITED
DURATION AND ALL THE FOLLOW UP
STUDIES WILL. WILL LEARN FROM
THIS LABORATORY I THINK IT IS
pREQUEST YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU MISTER
CLEAN- WITH THAT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT'S HIGHLY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BURKE HI-
I WHEN. GREAT LISTEN OR GRAYSON
I. LEVINE LEVINE I MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS ARE
A QUIRK NO WORK NO RIVAS SALIDO
HI THERE- I. THE BILL IS ON CALL
FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU THAT BILLS
OUT FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU VERY
LONG CALL I'M SORRY THE BILL'S
ON CALL FIVE TWO ONE- OKAY.
LIVING TO FILE ITEM FOR ME BE
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT I DO WANT TO
ENCOURAGE AUTHORS TO GET DOWN
HERE WE ARE GOING TO RUN ON A
VERY TIGHT SCHEDULE TODAY AND
THOSE WHO HAVE NOT WHO NEED TO
ADD ON I SUGGEST YOU START
HEADING THIS WAY AS WELL WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HOLD MINUTES LONG
AS NORMAL SO. I HAVE THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KIRK OVER WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND BARBARA QUICK MOVES
MISTER GRAYSON SECONDS SO THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR KEEP IT VERY
SHORT- AS YOU DO THIS BILL IS A
VERY IMPORTANT AS ONE OF OUR
MAIN FOCUSES ON OUR HOUSING
TOWARDS THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
HOUSING PRODUCTION. IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS THE STATE BUDGET HAS
INCREASED ITS INVESTMENT IN THE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM BY FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT GIVES US A BIGGER
BANG FOR THE BUCK AND MAXIMIZES
OUR PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOMES BY ALLOWING THE TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE TO PAIR THE
STATE TAX CREDITS WITH EITHER 4%
OR 9% FEDERAL. CREDITS AS
CONDITIONS BEST DICTATE AND
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
PAIRED THE STATE CREDITS WITH 4%
FEDERAL CREDIT BECAUSE OF THE 4%
FEDERAL CREDITS THAT WERE UNDER
SUBSCRIBED AT THAT TIME AS WE
KNOW THINGS HAVE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE THEN AND NOW
THOSE SAME CREDITS ARE OVER
SUPPORT SUBSCRIBE THREE TO ONE.
EACH 4% CREDIT DEVELOPMENT THAT
RECEIVE STATE CREDIT SIMPLY
DISPLACES ANOTHER OR THE
DEVELOPMENT SO SIMPLY I HAVE
MORE NOTES HERE BUT I WILL SAY
THIS WILL- IN SIMPLE TERMS ALLOW
US TO MOVE FORWARD WITH GETTING
THESE CREDITS TO. THOSE WHO ARE
BUILDING THESE HOMES SO WE CAN
GET PEOPLE HOUSED THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS HERE I
DO OR- MISTER SUMMERS PLEASE.
WELCOME REMARKS BY REBEL TWENTY
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT
IN HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BRAVERY ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
. SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE MAIN LINE FOR SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY
MODERATOR. IT WAS TO COME IN
SUPPORT IN A PRESS ONE THERE AT
THIS TIME. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NINE
MODERATORS ARE CAN WE OPEN THE
LINE PLEASE FOR ANY MAINLINE ON
THE FOR THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. IF YOU
LIKE TO COME IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANKYOU
SO MUCH QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NINE
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOAT- THIS QUIRKS OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. HIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISSILE YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BURKE HI
ARI LYNN. GRAY GRAYSON. LEVINE
LEVINE I MAYES MULLIN
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK HI ARE YOU RIVAS ZERO
NUMBER THEY ARE NOT VOTING. THE
BILL SOME CALL FIVE ZERO THAT
BILLS ON CALL FIVE ZERO THANK
YOU MISS SO THANK YOU MEMBERS. I
HAD FOR THOSE LISTENING AUTHORS
WHO HAVE BILLS REMAINING WE
SUGGEST WE RECOMMEND YOU COME
DOWN NOW. PLEASE MISTER
GALLAGHER FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TWELVE FORTY NINE WOULD.
PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT A.
B. TWELVE FORTY NINE I WHICH
WOULD CLARIFY CALIFORNIA'S TAX
CODE TO EXCLUDE ALL TYPES OF
CLAIMANTS FROM PAIN STATE TAXES
ON COMPENSATIONFOR DAM OF THE
VALE OUT OF P. GENIES FIRE
VICTIMS TRUST. HI THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO. LOST
THEIR HOMES THEIR PROPERTY THEIR
LIVES THEIR LOVED ONES- WHEN
THEY RECEIVE THEIR SETTLEMENT
FROM P. GENIE OUT OF THE CAMP
FIRE- AND SEVERAL OTHER FIRES
FROM- THESE PAST YEARS. THAT
THAT THAT WOULD NOT BE TAX AND
THAT WOULD BE A HUGE BENEFIT FOR
THEM- AS- MANY OF THEM ARE THERE
MAYBE NOT GETTING- YOU KNOW FULL
COMPENSATION- OUT OF THIS- NOW
THIS SETTLEMENT- SO THIS WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TO HELPING THEM
RECOVER TO REBUILD HOMES TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES- AND THIS
DEVASTATING TIME- AND SO I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. AND
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR ALL
OF YOUR HELP- AND YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS ISSUE AND FOR YOUR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND WORKING WITH
US- THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL
AND HOPE WE CAN MOVE IT FOR
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT FIRST- ANGELA KASLER
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CONNECT US. YES I'M CONNECTED
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HI THERE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE ON ANGELA KAPLER FROM
THE PARADISE CAMPFIRE AND THERE
ARE CURRENTLY THREE TAXABLE
PORTIONS TO THAT FIRE VICTIMS
TRUST SETTLEMENT ONE IS
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS PERSONAL
INCOME AND BUSINESS INCOME. MOST
CLAIMS WILL HAVE EITHER OR BOTH
AN EMOTIONAL DISTRESS OR DON'T
DANGER DETERMINATION AND
CURRENTLY PRELIMINARY PAYMENTS
ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED WILDFIRE
VICTIMS TRUSTEDID AWAITS THE
CLAIM DETERMINATION. 38% OF
CLAIMANTS HERESY DETERMINATION
WHILE 62% HAVE NOT INCLUDING MY
FAMILY IN BOTH SPEAKERS HERE
TODAY IT IS TAX PREPARATION TIME
AND WE IMPLORE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER FIRE SURVIVORS TAX
RELIEF ON THE SETTLEMENTS AND
THE ATTORNEYS AN IRS WILL
RECEIVE MORE THAN THE SURVIVORS.
AND FOR EXAMPLE A PRELIMINARY
PAYMENT EXAMPLE IS THAT
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS STATE.
420-005-2512 MY ABOUT TAXES AND
FEES ONE THIRD GOES TO THE
ATTORNEY AT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINETEEN
PERCENT- I WENT TO A CLAIM FOR
CONTRACTORS FOR EXPENSES. 28% OF
THE FIFTH ELEMENT WENT TO THE
IRAN AND 9% WENT TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND- TOTAL
TAXES AND FEES WERE 370-009-0090
FIVE DOLLARS OR 89% OF THAT
PRELIMINARY PAYMENT OF FORTY TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY FIVE.
THROUGH THE NET IS FOUR THOUSAND
AND TWENTY YOUR TAXES FEES.
WHICH IS 10% OF THE. FORTY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE POINT FIVE. IMINT
THOUGH THIS IS ENOUGH MONEY TO
BUY CAO MEDIA C. AND MICHAEL
SALE TAX MY FAMILY BEEN A
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND.
REPLACING OUR DAILY LIVE ITEMS
SINCE TWO EIGHTEEN. WE ACTUALLY
MOVE DURING HOPE IT HAD TO MAIL
ORDER EVERYTHING AND HAS PAID
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT POINT 25%
SALES TAX OR FOURTEEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS. NOT BEEN
SALES TAX GOES TO THE GENERAL
FUND BUT PERHAPS ALL FIRE
SURVIVORS ARE DOING OUR PART TO
KEEP CITIES COUNTIES MAKANI
ROLLING ALONG BY REPLACING MARC
THINGS. I ALSO WORRY THAT WE
MIGHT BE IN A NEW TAX BRACKET IF
WE HAPPEN TO RECEIVE A
DETERMINATION. ACTUALLY PUT
ALLOW REPLACING BIG TICKET ITEMS
WITH TAX RELIEF OF THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN DOLLARS OR NINE PERCENT.
THAT WOULD GIVE ME A TOTAL OF
EIGHT THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN DOLLARS WHICH WOULD
ALMOST ALLOW ME TO BUY A
900-900-0500 DOLLARS GENERATOR.
FOR POWER SAFETY SHUT OFF THEIR
POWER OUTAGE LIVING. AND WHAT
WOULD I DO WITH MY DETERMINATION
IF I EVER HEAR BACK THE QUOTE
FROM MY DRIVEWAY ENCROACHMENT
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND ARE
RETAINING WALLS TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND QUOTE. AT THE FUNDS
TRICKLING THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WHO KNOWS WHAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY DO THAT
SETTLEMENT AFTER TAXES AND FEES
WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH TO REBUILD.
SO PLEASE SUPPORT TAX RELIEF FOR
SURVIVORS MAYBE THAT WILL HELP
TO ALLOW SOME OF US TO BUY A
REFRIGERATOR. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK MISS KAY I HOPE IT OF YOU
MORE THAN TWO BY. FREDERATOR
MARC FOR. THROUGH ARE SAYING IF
YOU YEAH ARE SICK WITNESS- WILL
ABRAMS. YOU PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH MR ABRAMS PLEASE. HE GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE BOOKING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WILL ABRAMS
AND I AM TESTIFYING TODAY IS A
VICTIM OF THE TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN P. JEANNIE FIRES I'M
ALSO TESTIFYING TODAY IS A PROUD
CINEMA COUNTY RESIDENTS URGING I
GO FOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
NECESSARY TASKS REALLY PER
VICTIMS WITHOUT THE AMENDED TAX
THE STATE IT WITHIN THE AMENDED
TEXAS SECTION ONE SUBSECTION B.
AT THIS BILL SUPPORTS THOSE
BEING PROVIDED COMPENSATION
THROUGH THE FIRE VICTIMS TRUST
AS SOMEONE WHO IS HEAVILY
ENGAGED IN THE P. JEANNIE
BANKRUPTCY I WANT TO PROVIDE
SOME CONTEXT ABOUT HOW AND WHY
THIS FIRE IN TRUST WAS FORMED.
YOUR STANCE WHY RELEASE PROVIDE
TO THIS BILL IS SO. NECESSARY
FIRST CONSIDER IN ASSOC WITH THE
TRUST ARCH. FROM AB TEN FIFTY
FOUR FROM CONSIDERATION UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES ONE.%
INSTEAD THE MISTRUST WAS SET UP
AS A SHIELD FOR P. JEANNIE
INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS YES OUR
TRUST BUILDING 25% OF P.
JEANNIE. AND MAKING UP 50% OF
OUR COMPENSATION WAS UNJUSTLY
POSITION TO BENEFIT INVESTORS
THAT CASH OUT. AND GAINED OTHER
MARKET ADVANTAGES ALL THE WHILE
WE THE VICTIMS RACKED UP
ADDITIONAL LEGAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES. SUFFERED IN
TRAILERS WAITED TO REBUILD OUR
HOMES AND IN SOME CASES DIED.
WAITING TO SELL OUR STOCK. THESE
INJUSTICES AMONG OTHERS REASONS
ARE WHY THE VICTIMS YOU NEED THE
TAX RELIEF THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED THROUGH THIS BILL. THE
LAST POINT I WILL MAKE TO THIS
COMMITTEE IS THAT THIS BILL
WHILE CRITICAL. ISN'T ENOUGH.
DESPITE THE MOTIONS AND
ARGUMENTS I PROVIDED WITHIN US
BANKRUPTCY COURT WITHIN THE CPUC
AND RECENTLY BEFORE JUDGE ALSO.
ALL OF THE COURTS HAVE INDICATED
THEIR HANDS ARE LARGELY TIED DUE
TO EIGHTY TEN FIFTY FOUR. QUITE
FRANKLY WE NEED YOUR HELP I URGE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DOUBLE TAP
THIS BILL WITH. BROAD SUPPORT.
AND TO PUSH P. G. OTHERS CAN
MAKE GOOD ON THIS THIRTEEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR TAX. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WAY IN ROOM WHICH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEEING THEM
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE MAIN LINE FOR SPRING
TESTIMONY. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
JUST A MOMENT. RIGHT. AND HER TO
GO TO LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CHRIS CLOSE
TOGETHER AND I'M A RESIDENT
FORMER RESIDENT OF PARADISE- AND
I WOULD LIKE TO STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO FOCUS.
AND PATH TO HELP BUILD UP OF THE
SUFFERING THAT WE BECAUSE THAT
HAS BEEN CAUSED TO OUR- I KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE OF REFERENCE THAT-
PANDEMIC AND HOW TOUGH
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE FOR
EVERYBODY BUT IMAGINE LIVING
pFOR THE PANDEMIC. MATT LOSING
YOUR TOWN YOUR FAMILY YOUR
COMMUNITY AND THEN AT THE END OF
THIS ONLY HAVE TO REALIZE THAT
YOUR LAWYER FEES ARE GOING TO BE
PAID FOR YOUR TAXES THE STATE'S
GONNA TAKE. TAKE TAXES FROM YOU
AND ALL YOUR TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE IT BACK HOME I'M STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO HELP MOVE
US THROUGH THE TIME. M. AND I
ALSO HEAR. PEOPLE BEING AFRAID
TO COME I NEED YOU TO BE. NOT
SILVA LOW INCOME WELL THIS WAS A
LOWER IN. AREA LAST ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO. VOTE AND HELP SOME
OF THE THROUGH THE- TIMELINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE WANT
TO SEE YOU GET HOME TO.
MODERATOR THE NEXT PERSON IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. MEXICO TO LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHARON
STONE MAN I'M CALLING FROM THE
PARADISE CAMPFIRE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. I PLEAD FOR YOUR HELP
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WITH
LINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI OF COURSE ISN'T
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I AM A CAMPFIRE. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT TO THE TWO NINE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES MY
NAME'S DAVID GLEBA I'M A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FIRE SURVIVOR FROM
CINEMA MY PARTNER OWNS TWO
PROPERTIES IN CALIFORNIA OUR
PROPERTY IN CINEMA AND A
PROPERTY IN REDDING PGD FIRES
BURNED BOTH OF THOSE PROPERTIES
IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS. FOR THE
FOR THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN FIRE WE
ARE STILL WAITING FOR SETTLEMENT
DETERMINATION FROM THE FIRE
VICTIM TRUST FOUR YEARS LATER
FOR THE LOG FIRE THAT AFFECTED
HIS PROPERTY IN READING OF
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AGO THEY HAVE A
MEDIATION SCHEDULED FOR THE END
OF THIS MONTH. SO THOSE WERE
SAID TO BE DELAYED TO THE
BANKRUPTCY UNFORTUNATELY ARE
REALLY GETTING THE RAW END OF
THE STICK AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. REMINDER I AM I HATE
TO DO THIS AND I KNOW WE'RE
SPEAKING WITH VICTIMS BUT IF WE
CAN CONDENSE OUR COMMENTS TO
NAME. NAME AND AFFILIATION. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
GREAT ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THING- MR
WITH. YEAH I JUST- DEFINITE
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS-
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY OF THE
WITNESSES THAT CALLED IN AS WELL
AND TO SEE THE LIST OF
CONSTITUENTS THAT HAVE- I DON'T
THINK I'LL BE GOOD TO SEE WHAT'S
ON MY- WHATEVER OFFER SYSTEMS
CALLED BUT- YOU KNOW REALLY THIS
. ALARMING TO ME. HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING THROUGH
THIS- YEARS LATER SO THANK YOU
SIR. YEAH I WANNA THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HIS TENACITY
AND HIS PATIENCE WITH THE
PROCESS THROUGH CO OPENED AND
EVERYTHING AND SOME OF OUR OTHER
ISSUES WE FACED ON THIS MEASURE-
BUT CAN. YOU ARE REPRESENTING
YOUR CONSTITUENTS WHILE AND- I
HAVE BEEN TO PARADISE WITH YOU
AND I APPRECIATE I HAVE
APPRECIATED WHAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THE FAMILY. THROUGH SO WITH
THAT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO COOK.
YEAH I JUST SAID THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN AGAIN AND- I WAS GONNA
SAY EXACTLY THAT THAT YOU CAME
TO PARADISE AND YOU. SAW THE
DEVASTATION YOURSELF AND I JUST
APPRECIATED YOUR SUPPORT- THE-
THROUGHOUT THIS AND THIS ISN'T
ONLY JUST CAN'T FIRE THIS IS THE
BUTTE FIRE FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN
IN THE NORTH BAY FIRES. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MANY OF THESE VICTIMS
ARE TO SEND A- A TERRIBLE
SITUATION- AND I'VE BEEN WAITING
ON THE SETTLEMENT MONEY SO IT'S
ALMOST AT LEAST WE CAN DO. IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THEY DON'T PAY
ANY TAX ON THIS- AND I THINK
THERE'S OTHER THINGS WE CAN DO
THAT WILL THAT WILL HELP WORK ON
TO GET HER. AND OTHER AVENUES
BUT- WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AT THE VERY LEAST THESE-
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMPENSATED AND
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THIS.EXTRA
BURDEN OF HAVING TO PAY TAXES ON
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WHEN THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE I
WOULD LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF I'M NOT
ALREADY I'M NOT SURE I MIGHT
THAT IT'S BEEN SO LONG.
ABSOLUTELY WITH THAT- CLEVELAND
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
MISSILE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL. YOU CAN IT STEEP. TWO
BURKE HI BURKE I NGUYEN. GREAT
GRAYSON. LEVINE I MEAN I MAYES
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS ARTWORK HI BURKE I
RIVAS. ZERO HI HERE TO OUR- SIX
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT SIX ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANCHESTER
O'DONNELL FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
THREE SIXTY FIVE WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY. THINGS ALL NICE AND
CLEAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB THREE SIX FIVE
WHICH WILL INCENTIVIZE THE
ADOPTION OF CLEANER HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS BY PROVIDING A PARTIAL
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR ZERO AND
NEAR ZERO. DRAYAGE TRUCKS. I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY SAYING
THAT I AM ACCEPTING THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT PROPOSED IN
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS.
STRAIGHT TRUCKS PLAY A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S FREIGHT
INFRASTRUCTURE BY TRANSPORTING
CONTAINERS AND OTHER MATERIALS
FROM PORTS TO RAIL YARDS
WAREHOUSES AND DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS. HISTORICALLY THESE
TRUCKS AND HARD BY DIESEL FUEL.
A SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION AND THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF THESE VEHICLES AND
OTHER SOURCES OF GHG OUR STATE
IS COMMITTED TO AMBITIOUS
EMISSION GOALS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS OF WHAT YOU ARE
ALL AWARE. HOWEVER DESPITE
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY THE
TRANSITION TO CLEAN DRESS TRUCKS
WILL BE AN ALL OUT BATTLE.
BECAUSE OF THE PRICE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DIESEL TRUCKS AND THE
NEWER CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES.
UNLESS THE STATE PROVIDES
FUNDING TO OFFSET THE COSTS IT%
WILL BE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
DRAYAGE TRUCK OPERATORS TO
AFFORD THE CLEANER ALTERNATIVES.
AB THREE SIXTY FIVE WILL EASE
THE TRANSITION TO CLEANER DREAD
TRUCKS BYE EXEMPTING THE
PURCHASE OF NEW AND USED ZERO
AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION TRUCK
DRAYAGE TRUCKS FROM. SALES TAX
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT CLEANER
TECHNOLOGY WILL BE AFFORDABLE
FOR CALIFORNIANS STRAIGHT TRUCK
OPERATORS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ADD THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ON AMENDMENTS TO
PROTECT TAX REVENUES FOR
COUNTIES. DUE TO THE TIMING
ISSUES WE WILL TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND THE NEXT
COMMITTEE- WITH THAT BACKING
MANAGER. THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND
THEIR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT FIRST BE
PART OF LOS ANGELES WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US.
ERIC MARTEL ERIC MARTEL. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ERIC MARTEL LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE PORT OF
LOS ANGELES WE APPRECIATE THAT
WE MEMBER O'DONNELL'S HAPPENING
THIS REFORM WHICH WILL HELP
CLEAN THE AIR AROUND THE
TEMPERATURE BAY AND STATEWIDE WE
SHARE THE STATE CALL A REDUCING
EMISSIONS IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE PORT OF LA AND LONG BEACH
ADOPTED A CLEANER ACTION PLAN
THAT SET A GOAL OF HAVING ALL.
TRUCKS DURING THE PORT A CHEAP
ZERO TAILPIPE EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN APRIL THIS
EVIDENCE HERE AT THE PORT OF LA
WILL COMMENCE COLLECTION OF A
CLEAN TRUCK INTENT OF GREAT THAT
IS EXPECTED TO GENERATE UP TO
FORTY FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY TO
HELP OFFSET THE COST OF A ZERO
EMISSION DRAYAGE TRUCK. FORTY
FIVE BILLION ANNUALLY NOT ENOUGH
OF US OFF THAT THE SEVERAL
BILLION OF DOLLARS THAT WILL BE
NEEDED TO TRANSFORM THE DRAINAGE
FLEET TO ZERO EMISSION WE NEED
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS TO HELP
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL WAY TO REDUCE
THE COST. AYE NEAR NEAR THE A
NEAR THERE A MISSION DRAIN
STRUKHOFF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS THE
USED VEHICLE TRUCK THAT MANY
TRAITS OPERATORS USE CAUGHT
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND THAT MEANS
YOU'RE ASKING DRAYAGE OPERATORS
TO PURCHASE AND AFTER THAT
CAUGHT SEVEN TIMES MORE THAN
WHAT NORMALLY ACQUIRED FOR THEIR
BUSINESS THIS BILL WILL HELP
MAKE THE NEW ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS MORE AFFORDABLE EVERY
LITTLE BIT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IF
WE ACT NOW WE ARE THINKING THAT
THEY'RE NOT THE MARKET WERE. TO
ABOUT INCLUDING BUDGET AND
BUBBLE AND HAD OURS ZERO
COLLEAGUES FIVE ZERO STRANGE WE
ARE PROUD TO COSPONSOR THE AFTER
AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU WE
ANOTHER WITH. FROM THE HER
TRUCKING IS SO. WITH MODERATOR
PLEASE US NOW. HELLO AUDIBLE CHU
A MEMBER MY NAME IS MATT SHOP I
AM THE CEO OF THE HARPER
TRUCKING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT AND
HISTORIC MEASURE BEFORE YOU
TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIX
FIVE THE HOBBIT TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION- HDA THE NONPROFIT
COALITION OF TRADE TRUCKING IN
SUPPLY CHAIN COMPANIES SERVICE
IN CALIFORNIA'S COURTS WITH MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED TRUCKING
COMPANIES TO MAKE UP THE RANKS
OF THE GAA GAA OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S MARINE CARGO. IN
OUR AT THE FOREFRONT OF EFFORTS
TRANSIT TRUCK FLEETS TO LOW
KNOCKS IN ZERO EMISSIONS
TECHNOLOGY VOICE SHE IS NOT
PERSPECTIVE PRESCRIPTIVE ON HOW
OUR MEMBERS MEET THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR OWN
INTERNAL SUSTAINABILITY GOALS
OUR EFFORTS HAVE BEEN TO MAKE.
THESE GOALS MORE ACHIEVABLE BY
PROMOTING CONCEPT THEIR MOVE
HURDLES OUR MEMBERS FACE IN
TRANSITIONING THEIR FLEETS TO
NEWER AND CLEANER TRUCK
TECHNOLOGY AB THREE SIXTY FIVE
HELPS TO MITIGATE THE INITIAL
ACQUISITION COST OF THE VEHICLES
ALLOWING MORE COMPANIES TO MAKE
A BUSINESS DECISION CONVERTER
POLICE TO MORE SUSTAINABLE BUT
QUITE EXPENSIVE TECHNOLOGY.
PERSONAL ATTACKS THE PURCHASE OF
A NEAR ZERO KNOCKS THIRTEEN
NEIGHBOR A HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS BEFORE TAXES
AND FEES FOR ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY THE PURCHASE PRICE OF
THE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO WELL IN
EXCESS OF. THREE HUNDRED TO
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. DESPITE IT SENATE.
OFFSET THE- OF LARA ZERO
EMISSION TRUCK VERSION. TAXES
AND FEES ARE NOT ACCOUNTED IN
THE IN AND OF BY DOWN. TRUCKING
CO APPROACH NEW DOC AND ZERO
EMISSION CHAU. PROPOSED FOR
STATE SALES ON THE ARMOR PRICE
OF THE V. IF NO CHANGES. TO THE
TAX THE SETS. ON LOWER KNOCKS
ZERO TRUCK. THE SALES TAX WILL
AMONG. PRICED HEAVY DUTY MISSION
COST OVER THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WOULD RAY ABOUT THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED OVER
AWFULLY ONE THIRD OF THE TOTAL
ACQUISITION COST. OF A BRAND NEW
DIESEL TRUCK BUILT FOR DRAINAGE.
COSTS TO BE PUT ON TO THE BOTTOM
LINE OF THE TRANSACTION.
INCLUDING A FEDERAL EXCISE TAX
RATE OF 12% ON HEAVY DUTY
DRAYAGE VEHICLES PUTTING TOTAL
TAX EXPOSURE CLOSE TO SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WHILE MANY
COMPANIES WOULD LIKE TO INVEST
IN NEAR ZERO ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGY AS THEY LOOK TO
REPLACE. ENGINE BURKE FLEETS THE
SALES TAX EXPOSURE HAS BEEN A
MAJOR CHALLENGE WHY THE THREE
SIX FIVE DOES NOT REMOVE IT. THE
BARRIER COMPANIES FACE. TRYING
TO CONVERT PLEASE STAND NEAR
ZERO ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY.
REMOVING THE SALES TAX OBSTACLE
FOR LOCAL TRUCKING COMPANIES
SERVICING CALIFORNIA SPORTS.
HELP SOLVE AT LEAST ONE MAJOR
ISSUE. P. H. D. IS PROUD TO NOT
ONLY SUPPORT. AB THREE SIXTY
FIVE BUT ALSO TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO TRUE
SUSTAINABILITY. BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC WE
APPLAUD ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
MANY OTHER ISSUES. AB THREE
SIXTY FIVE WILL HELP PUT MORE
CALIFORNIA'S TRUCKERS ANILOX
EXERTION TRUCKS. HELPING KEEP
HELP SUPPORT. IN THE WORLD
WALLOWING INDUSTRY TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. RESPECT CRESTOR
SUPPORT WITH A VOTE. WHAT I VOTE
ON AB THREE SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM. WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. C. NG NINE
THE MODERATOR NOW PLAY OPEN
MAINLINE FOR SCORE TESTIMONY.
NAME AND AFFILIATION.
ELECTRICITY IS A PRESS ONE ZERO
THIS TIME A PERSON GO TO LAW
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
NUMBERS INJURY AMPLY THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT AND WE THINK
WE OUGHT TO. THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE. NEXT TO THE LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BLOWED MATURING COMMITTEE DRAWL
COOK FOR THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WE'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
pOF THE CENTRE FOR TRANSPORTATION
ENVIRONMENT SUPPORT. NEXT TO THE
TWO ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOHNSON PLAY ON BEHALF OF THE
PORTS IN DIEGO SUPPORT A. B.
THREE SIX FIVE. NICHOLAS NINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
OR MOMENTARILY ON BEHALF LONG
BEACH AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANKS TO THE TIMELINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KAYLA
OCCURRING ON BEHALF OF THE
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT. AND
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO THERE'S
IN Q. THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING THEM WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN
LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. DO YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. OFFERS
WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TURN NUMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ THE CORPORATE ANTI THERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. YOU. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO OTHERS IN Q. THANK
YOU ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
UNDERSTAND YOU'LL BE ACCEPTED
SETTING THE TECH AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED IN THE NOW SYSTEM WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO COOK. YES
ACCEPTING THE MOMENT SO YES IN
HERE THE THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AS FOR AN ITEM THANK YOU-
WE HAVE A- MOTION FROM GRAYSON A
SECOND FROM PETRIE-NORRIS AND
WITH THAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED. TO APPROPRIATIONS
WAS HIGHLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. BURKE HI BURKE I WHEN FIVE.
WHEN I GRAY GRAYSON. LEVINE
LEVINE I MAYES MULLIN WELL AND I
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS
ARTWORK HI BURKE I READ THIS
SCENARIO ALL RIGHT THERE- I.
EIGHT ZERO THE BILL THEY'LL
EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MANAGER LIVING A FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB TO SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOLUNTEERS
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB TWO
SEVENTEEN WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES WHO'VE BEEN STRUGGLING
DUE TO INFLATION AND THE IMPACTS
OF THE PANDEMIC PURCHASE SCHOOL
SUPPLIES FOR THEIR CHILDREN BY
CREATING A BACK TO SCHOOL SALES
TAX HOLIDAY. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
NATION AND IT DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
A. TWENTY TWENTY REPORT FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AEA PLANNING
AND URBAN RESEARCH RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION FOUND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH SALES TAX RATE
REINFORCES STRUCTURAL
INEQUALITY. THIS IS BECAUSE LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS HAVE A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR INCOME TAX
THAN THE AVERAGE CONSUMER LET ME
REPEAT THAT THIS IS BECAUSE LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS HAVE A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR INCOME TAX.
THAN THE AVERAGE CONSUMER THE
INEQUITBLE IMPACT OF CALIFORNIA
STATE SALES TAX HINDERS THE
ABILITY OF LOW INCOME FAMILIES
TO PURCHASE SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND
ADEQUATELY PREPARE THEIR
CHILDREN FOR SCHOOL. THIS YEAR
PARENTS WITH CHILDREN IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS ARE
PROJECTED TO SPEND NEARLY EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS ON A SET OF
SUPPLIES. GIVEN THAT THE MANY
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE ALREADY
TAKING ON DEBT AND DELAYING
NECESSARY PURCHASES AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC. MANY PARENTS
ARE CHOOSING BETWEEN ADEQUATELY
PREPARING THEIR CHILDREN FOR
SCHOOL. OR PAYING RENT BUYING
MEDICINE- EVEN PURCHASING
GROCERIES PARENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO MAKE THAT DECISION. AB TWO
SEVENTEEN HELPS MAKES SCHOOL
SUPPLIES MORE AFFORDABLE FOR ALL
. CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY CREATING A BACK
TO SCHOOL SALES TAX HOLIDAY IT
IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE PROVIDE TAX
RELIEF FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES WHO HAVE STRUGGLED TO
MAKE ENDS MEET DURING THIS
PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT
WE WILL LIKELY SEE A
MULTIBILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS THIS
YEAR. I DO HAVE A WITNESS ON THE
LINE- CONSTITUENT FROM THE
THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
ALONG THE HARO- WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE CONNECT US NOW. HEARING NOW I CAN YES. I THANK
YOU VERY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALLADARES FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE- EVERY YEAR
FAMILIES LIKE MINE WILL SPEND
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS ON SCHOOL
SUPPLIES FOR THEIR CHILDREN-
AND- WHAT THE PANDEMIC IF YOU
MADE IT. EVEN HARDER PREPARING
KIDS FOR SCHOOL MORE DIFFICULT
INFLATION HAS READ THE CARD
EVERY ITEM IMAGINABLE AND
PARENTS OF NEEDED TO PURCHASE
MORE SUPPLIES DR CHILDREN
NAVIGATE ONLINE LEARNING AND NEW
SCHOOL FIFTY PARTICLES
PARTICLES. AB TWO SEVENTEEN IS
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT CREATE
THE BACK TO SCHOOL SALES TAX
HOLIDAY THIS WILL HELP THE MONEY
BACK INTO THE POCKETS OF ALL
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS
ESPECIALLY THE MOBILE FAMILIES.
STRUGGLE FINANCIALLY TO
ESPECIALLY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
BY PASSING AB TWO SEVENTEEN THE
COMMITTEE CAN PUT THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN FIRST AND HELP FAMILIES
AFFORD. THOSE NECESSARY BOTH BY
. EARLIER YOU TO VOTE FOR EVEN
TO THE- THANK YOU. ARE THEREANY
AT ANY WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WHAT THE MODERATOR
NOW PLEASE OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE
FOR THE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. HE
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE. FINE THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINES OPEN YOU
CAN HEAR. I'LL QUICKLIME FORTY
NINE- DROP THAT ACU. AND THERE'S
NO NOTHING Q. I UNDERSTAND ANY
CHAPTER TWO WILL BE TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION BEHALF OF THE
COVERAGE HIS ASSOCIATION WITH
THE MODERATE PLEASE CONNECT US
NOW. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- ANY CHALLENGE SPLIT
ADVOCATE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. A C. T.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTEEN WELL WE UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO HELP
PARENTS AND EDUCATORS. WITH BACK
TO SCHOOL COSTS FIFTY P. DOES
NOT SUPPORT THIS APPROACH AS IT
WOULD REDUCE OVERALL FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION. THE STATE CURRENTLY
PROVIDES APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
EXPENDITURES ANNUALLY WHICH
MEANS- THIRTY BILLION IS
REDIRECTED AWAY FROM SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES EACH YEAR DUE
TO TAX CREDITS. WE BELIEVE THAT
PROPOSITION NINETY SHOULD BE
PROTECTED FROM TO FURTHER
REDUCTIONS BY CREATING NEW OR
EXPANDING EXISTING- TAX
STRUCTURES FOR THESE REASONS WE
MUST OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU STENY BUT IN THE
ROOM RUSSIAN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THE NINE WITH THE
MODERATE PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN
LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION HERE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. OF
PURCHASE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN
MEMBERS CATALINA SANCHEZ CARBON
PRICE THEY'RE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PALOS MISSILE WITH A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION- WE
ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ENOUGH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SOMEONE.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS BILL ITS SIDE AS A PARENT
OF SCHOOL AGE KIDS AYE I'M
ENTERTAINED BY IT AND I THINK A
LOT OF CALIFORNIANS ARE I THINK
WE DID OPPORTUNITY SPEAK DURING
SESSION ON THE FLOOR TODAY ABOUT
SOME OF MY CONCERNS- WITH REGARD
TO IT BEING ESSENTIALLY LIKE AN
ACTUAL HOLIDAY INVOLVING A
COUPLET OR NUMBER OF DAYS OF THE
YEAR LEADING TO THE SCHOOL YEAR
AND- CERTAINLY THE NEED FOR
SCHOOL SUPPLIES IS A YEAR ROUND
ONE WE CAN ANTICIPATE WHAT'S AS
WE WANT TO BUY FOR OUR STUDENTS.
BUT ON WE REALLY KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO THE
YEARS WHY I'D HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT- I DO SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED DURING THE PANDEMIC
ACCORDING OF CERTAIN SCHOOL
MATERIALS AND SUPPLIES- AS WELL
AS ON. YOU KNOW WITH THIS
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
SMALL ARE NOT SMALL BUT- YOU
KNOW SMALL BUSINESSES BRICK AND
MORTAR BUSINESSES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT THEM THAT
TIME THIS WOULD ENCOURAGE- A LOT
OF THAT GREAT IN PERSON
PURCHASING TO OCCUR- IN A
CONDENSED PERIOD OF TIME
ALLOWING FOR OR CAUSING PERHAPS
NOT THE SAME DISTANCING THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT WE
SHOULD MAYBE THINK ABOUT INTO
THE FUTURE SO. WITH THOSE
CONCERNS AND ALSO KNOWING THAT A
COMPUTER COULD BREAK A PRINTER
COULD BREAK THE NEED FOR MORE
INK- CAN OCCUR THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR THAT WE THINK ABOUT IT ON
IN A DIFFERENT IN A DIFFERENT
WAY THAT'S NOT STOCK A SHORTENED
PERIOD OF TIME- I'M NOT. I DON'T
WANNA WRITE YOUR BILL FOR YOU-
SO FOR DOING IT IS FOR A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF MONEY OR A CERTAIN OR
NO WE'RE JUST NOT GONNA CHECK
TAX WHAT WE THINK ARE SCHOOL
SUPPLIES- BUT THERE MIGHT BE A
DIFFERENT WAY TO DO IT THAT I
THINK WOULD BE MORE EFFECTIVE
FOR. THAT B. SOME OF THOSE CAN
THAT I ALSO- BUT ALL ALL SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY TO ALLOW YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON IT AND I GO
THAT I THINK THAT GOES TO ALSO
SAY THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY LOOK
AT THAT THE FACT THAT THE SALES
TAX IS TOO HIGH FOR MANY
FAMILIES AND THAT SALES TAX IN
CALIFORNIA IS REGRESSIVE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS- LOW
INCOME FAMILIES SO I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE WITH YOU
AND I' THE MOM OF A FOUR YEAR
OLD AND HAVE TWENTY ONE NIECES
AND NEPHEWS SO I HAVE LOTS OF
BROTHERS AND SISTERS TELLING ME
HOW MUCH THEY SPEND ON K.
THROUGH TWELVE SUPPLIES- AND
OPEN TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
MAKING THIS ABOUT A BILL- AS
WELL. THANK YOU IN THE CARD YOU
ALL STAND WITH TEACHERS ON THIS
ONE IF WE WANT TO HELP LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WE CAN HELP LOWER
INCOME PEOPLE WE CAN INSTEAD OF
THAT MONEY GOING TO EVERYONE
WHETHER THEY NEED IT OR NOT BE
BETTER TO INCLUDE INCREASE FOR
EXAMPLE THE LOW INCOME TAX
CREDIT OR OTHER- PROGRAMS TO
HELP LOW INCOME PEOPLE FOR THAT
REASON I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. SEVEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IF PROMOTED
ME THANK YOU THE SERVICE
MEMBERS- I THOUGHT I HEARD
SENATOR OH NO SORRY. M. WELL
ADJUSTING OR TO MAKE A COMMENT
YOU KNOW WE ARE LOOKING AT A
THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SURPLUS IN THE STATE AND WHILE I
COMPLETELY AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY-
BELIEVE IN FULLY FUNDING OUR
EDUCATION I ALSO THINK THAT THIS
SURPLUS IT'S A ONE YEAR- THE
BILL THAT WOULD JUST TAKE PLACE
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO WE HAVE A
THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS. AND WE CAN AFFORDABLE
FULLY FUND AND SUPPORT FULLY
FUNDINGOUR K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT PARENTS
AND STUDENTS AND THAT'S THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE SPELL SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THEIR
MOTION. ALL MAKE MOTION PER A
SECOND. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- THE MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
PROCREATION MISS HOLLY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL- WHEN I AND I.
GREAT GRAYSON. GRAYSON I LEVINE
LEVINE I MAYES MULLIN. MON I
PETRIE-NORRIS THE TRAYNOR'S
ARTWORK NO WORK NO RIVAS SARAH
HI THERE- I. IT SIXTIES. FOR I
IT STARTED YET. MADAM CHAIR IT
IS SIX TO ONE OF THOSE OUT BILLS
ALL SIXTY ONE. NEXT ITEM WILL BE. THANK ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ISN'T
IT BY SEVEN MEMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO BE JOINING YOU TODAY
TO PRESENT AB SEVEN OH FOUR ON
BEHALF OF OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES. AT AND AT I WOULD
ALSO JUST LIKE TO START BY
SAYING THAT THE AUTHOR WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. HI THIS LEGISLATION
AB SEVEN ZERO FOUR IS REALLY
QUITE SIMPLE BUT IT COULD HAVE A
PROFOUND IMPACT. ON THOSE WHO
BENEFIT FROM IT. CURRENTLY THE
LOAN INTEREST DEDUCTION FOR
STUDENT LOANS IS CAPPED AT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AB SEVEN ZERO FOUR
WOULD REMOVE THIS CAP AND WOULD
ALLOW ALL STUDENT LOAN INTEREST
TO BE DEDUCTIBLE ANNUALLY. LAW
CALIFORNIA CANNOT FORGIVE
STUDENT LOAN THAT WE CAN MAKE IT
EASIER ON BORROWERS AND REWARD
THEM FOR A HIGHER DEGREE WHEN
TAX SEASON COMES AROUND. UP WITH
THAT I THAT WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE ONE WITNESS IN SUPPORT
WERE JOINED BY CHRISTOPHER ALONG
WITH THE CONFERENCE AS
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS. BUT
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS CHRIS
FURLONG I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
FORMER DELEGATE FROM THE
CONFERENCE OF CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS. THIS BILL PROVIDES
A SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM OF
TALENTED TEACHERS HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS ENGINEERS AND THE
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE SADDLED
WITH STUDENT LOAN DEBT. WHO
CONINUE TO LEAVE CALIFORNIA FOR
STATES WITH LOWER STATE INCOME
TAXES. UNDER CURRENT LAW
TAXPAYERS EARNING LESS THAN
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS MAY ONLY
DEDUCT UP TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN
INTEREST. GRADUALLY PHASED OUT
SO THAT TAXPAYERS EARNING MORE
THAN SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR. ARE UNABLE TO DEDUCT ANY
OF THEIR STUDENT LOAN INTEREST.
NEARING EXISTING FEDERAL LAWS
THE STATE CURRENTLY DOES MAKES
NO SENSE FOR CALIFORNIANS. MANY
OF WHOM ARE MAKING MONTHLY
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS THAT ARE
EQUAL TO OR MORE THAN THEIR RENT
OR MORTGAGE PAYMENTS. TOTAL
STUDENT LOAN DEBT HAS GROWN A
HUNDRED AND 57% IN JUST THE LAST
TWELVE YEARS. FROM FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
TO MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION TODAY. CALIFORNIANS
HAVE AN ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT BILLION IN
STUDENT LOAN DEBT. AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. ACCORDING TO
FORBES UNFORTUNATELY MORE THAN
40% OF BORROWERS ARE EXPECTED TO
DEFAULT ON THEIR LOANS BY NEXT
YEAR. AND THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY MADE THINGS
WORSE. STUDENT LOAN DEBT ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND PRESENTS
YET ANOTHER BARRIER TO SUCH
STUDENTS PRIVATE PRESENTE SHIN
AND PROFESSIONS WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION COSTS. STUDENT LOAN
DEBT FURTHER DISCOURAGES DOCTORS
LAWYERS SUCH AS MYSELF AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS FROM ENGAGING AND
SOCIALLY BENEFICIAL PUBLIC
INTEREST WORK AND AS EXPLAINED
IN THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTING LETTER.
FROM TAKING ON A LARGER MEDICARE
OR MEDICAID ALL PATIENT LOAD.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
SAVE FOR RETIREMENT SET ASIDE A
DOWN PAYMENT ON A HOME OR EVEN
JUST MEET THEIR MONTHLY PAYMENT
EXPENSES. I RESPECTFULLY OR
DRIVE OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. C. NONE WITH
THE MODERATE NOW PLEASE OPEN UP
THE MAIN LINE FOR SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY. FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ZERO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
RECOMMEND AGAIN AS A ONE AND
ZERO. LINE SIXTY YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ANSWERING ACTUALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU DOCTOR
BRINGS MEASURE FORWARD AND WE
THINK IT WILL- INCREASE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STUDENTS IN
THE PIPELINE TO COMMIT TO
PROVIDE SERVICE IN THE AND
ACCESS TO CARE AND PUT THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT. AND LINE
FIFTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON ANNA
BACK ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WITH THE
MODERATE PLEASE OPEN THE MAIN
LINE FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
TO AB SEVEN ZERO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO. IN THAT
LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR MIKE IS OPEN
. TURN MEMBERS CATALINA SANCHEZ
THE CORBIN CARE THERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND
OUTLINED THIRTY FIVE. AND THIRTY
FIVE- MY COULD OPEN. YOU A CALL
AS MUCH EITHER WITH A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
ALSO- RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
. IN THE BILL THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. THE COURT YES I WOULD SUPPORT
A BILL THAT ACTUALLY. GAVE
SUPPORT TO PEOPLE WHO WANTED TO
SERVE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
BUT I CAN'T SPORTS SOMETHING
WHERE THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
WOULD HAPPEN- I ALSO SUPPORT THE
CURRENT LAW WHICH- PHASES OUT
THESE DEDUCTIONS AS YOUR INCOME
GOES MUCH HIGHER AND IN SOME
CASES IT WELL. SO I JUST CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL AT THIS TIME
BUT I'M SURE YOU'LL GET ALL THE
VOTES YOU NEED FOR THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A YOU MEASURE THAT YOU
HAVE AGREED TO- SUPPORT I MEAN
TO AGREE TO ALL THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED. THANK YOU WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I WILL
SIMPLY ADD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND. I'M
OF. THE MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MS HIGHLAND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- WHEN I AND
II GRAY GRAYSON. RECENT I LEVINE
MAYES MULLIN MULLIN AYE
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS I
CLERK OF NO WORK NO RIVAS RIVAS
EYES STARED UP ART THIRTY ONE.
THE SIXTH ONE IT'S PAST THE VOTE
THE BOTH PASSED SIXTY SIXTY ONE
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU HALF AS NEW
DADDY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU M.
THE ONE. AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA OPEN ROLE ON THE ON CALL
BILLS WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER TEN
AND ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN THE
SILENT PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE
ITEM NUMBER TEN WHEN I WHEN I
RAY. MULLIN ONE I RIVAS
RIVERSIDE. IT'S WHEN THE BILL IS
PASSED BILLS PASSED. THE NEW
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN THE SILENT
PLEASE CALL FOR THE VOTE. WHEN
NOT VOTING WHEN NOT VOTING GREAT
MULLIN ONE I RIVAS RIVAS I. THE
BILL'S PAST SEVEN ZERO BILL
PASSED NOW IF WE CAN- MISS ALAN
TWO RECALL ALL FINANCES FROM
BEGINNING TO THE END ITEM NUMBER. ONE EIGHTY SIX ZERO SEVEN. RAY
GRAYSON GRAYSON I MULLIN. ONE I
RIVAS RIVAS I. NUMBER TWO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWELVE ZERO SIX
RAY GRAYSON. GRAYSON ARI MULLIN
ONE I'D RIVAS RIVAS AYE NUMBER
THREE AB ONE ONE FOUR SIX. GRAY
MOLEN MULLIN I RIVAS RIVAS I
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TWO FOUR
THREE. HEY MOLEN ONE I. RIVAS
RIVAS FIVE ITEM SIX AB TWO FOUR
NINE. ONE I RIVAS RIVAS HI. HM
EIGHT AB THREE TO FOUR. GRAY
MULLIN MULLIN AYE RIVAS RIVAS I
. ADAM LEVIN AB. ONE TWO FOUR
NINE. WHEN I WHEN I RATE MULLIN
. MULLIN I RIVAS RIVAS I. I'D M.
WE DON'T NEED TO TWELVE RATE. DO
YOU HAVE A GOOD ARE- WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF MISS BURKE IS SHE
COMING BACK OKAY. ITEM LINE
THIRTEEN AB THREE SIX FIVE.
REYES RIVAS RIVERSIDE. IDMS
SEVENTEEN AB TWO ONE SEVEN.
GREAT RIVAS RIVAS I. IDM
EIGHTEEN AB ONE FIVE SEVEN TWO
RAY MULLIN. WELL AND I RIVAS
RIVAS I'D. THAT WRAP THIS UP.
THAT ENDS OUR ASSEMBLY REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE HEARING
THANK YOU OF AND WE ARE INTEGER
THANK YOU. FIVE LIKE A VICTIM
HERE. WHAT WAS SO DARN- WHO
KNOWS. THE COMPANY ITSELF. WHAT
I. NOW WE THANK YOU.